This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个由 iHeart 播客带来的节目，保证是真人制作。你是否渴望做出真正的改变？LaCite 学院为你提供“戒瘾与护理”项目。掌握这些核心技能，
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and dependents. Construise a career enriching to service
陪伴并支持面临健康问题和依赖症的人群。在全加国的法语社区中，开启一段充实的服务职业生涯。如果你想提升法语能力，
of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
在 LaCite 学院这是完全可能的。今天就访问 CollegeLaC.a，这是由卫生部资助的全国健康法语培训联盟发起的一个项目。
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. .A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
那些眼睛里没有任何生机，它们变得漆黑。这把我吓坏了。恶魔，醒醒吧。我就是那个目睹了克里瓦克和德皮波
of Formation in Health Supposed by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder
行凶过程的女人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚时毫无悔意，显得十分镇定。我说，我没有罪。我要把这起案件上诉到底。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Bone Valley》节目中的《魔鬼采石场》。快乐至关重要，但它也总是难以捉摸，不过现在有一种全新且令人兴奋的方式来开启你的旅程，
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey
去追求一个更加快乐的人生。《快乐 101》。这是一档全新的播客，由我，霍达·科特比主持。如果你渴望获得启发，让你的快乐最大化，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的空中对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App，搜索《Joy 101》并立即收听。《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotb》由 CVS 呈现。
toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
每个人都把我当成一名足球运动员，但在成为任何角色之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与生活中的问题、错误、人际关系以及情绪共存，这一切从我出生起就开始了。这不是一档普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、发自内心的。这只是一些关于“活着意味着什么”的坦诚对话。我是哈维尔·“奇查里托”·埃尔南德斯，
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nand-es,
请在 iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learning to Be Human》。接下来的这件事本不该如此复杂，那就是移除一座种族主义者的雕像。而接下来的这件事本该容易得多，那就是在它的位置上竖起一座新的雕像。我是阿克拉·休斯，《叛逆精神》第二季的主题就是这两件事。当我看着这些雕像倒下时，我在想，我是在一个黑人占多数的城市长大的，而这座城市里对奴隶主的致敬比对被奴役之人的致敬还要多，这意味着什么？请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《叛逆精神》第二季。
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority black city, in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
大家好。我是杰玛·斯佩格，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》，在这一播客中，我们将探讨二十岁时经历的最大变化、重要时刻和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。非常高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析二十岁的心理。今天的对话是我一直非常期待进行的。因为如果要说有什么事情——可以说我们所有人，即使不是全部，也有很多人——在二十岁时都在苦苦挣扎，那就是这个不断循环的过程：试图变得更好，试图打破固有模式，试图停止去做那些明知不该做的事，却又不知为何总是回到原点。无论是拖延症、手机成瘾、电子烟还是饮酒。我想我们都有过这样的时刻。
Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Speg and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology. of our 20s, today's conversation is one that I've been wanting to have for a very long time. Because if there is something, I would say all of us, if not a lot of us struggle with in our 20s, it is this constant cycle of trying to become better, trying to break patterns, trying to stop doing things we know we shouldn't be doing, and just somehow always ending back where we started. whether it is procrastination, whether it is phone addiction, vaping, drinking. I think we've all had a moment.
我绝对有过这样的时刻，当时我曾对自己说：“这是我最后一次做这种事了。我要戒掉。我受够了。我要成为一个自律、有动力的人”，然而结果却并不管用。说实话，我觉得问题并不出在我们身上。我认为问题在于，我们实际上误解了背后的心理机制。以及改变究竟是如何发生的。所以今天，我们将深入探讨背后的科学与心理学，
I've definitely had a moment where I've been like, this is the last time I'm ever doing this. I'm quitting. I'm done. I'm going to become this disciplined, motivated person and it just doesn't work. I don't think the problem is with us, if I'm being honest. I think the problem is that we actually misunderstand the psychology behind why. and how change actually works. So today, we are going to do a deep dive into the science and the psychology behind
如何改变坏习惯——这可不是流于表面的计划。我们要超越单纯的自律。我们要抛开基础的建议，真正切入核心。为此，我们为本期节目请来了一位特别的嘉宾。她是一位哈佛培养的行为科学家。她专门研究改变是如何发生的。她是波士顿咨询集团（BCG）的董事总经理。她也是 BCG 行为科学实验室的创始人。
changing bad habits, not like a surface level plan. We're going to go beyond discipline. We're going to go beyond the basic advice and really get into it. And we are bringing on a special guest for this episode. She is a Harvard trained behavioral scientist. She specializes in studying how change works. She's a managing director at BCG. She's the founder of the BCG Behavioral Science Lab.
这位女士基本上把她整天的时间都用来系统地剖析人类行为了。她还做过一些非常精彩的 TED 演讲，其中有些演讲的观看次数甚至超过了 800 万次。她写过书。她有一本新书即将出版。她还为《哈佛商业评论》和《福布斯》撰过稿。她做过的事情实在是太多了。而且她也是一位澳大利亚老乡。朱莉娅·达尔，欢迎来到《二十岁心理学》。
This woman basically spends her entire day systematically breaking down human behavior. She's also done some amazing TED talks, some of which have been viewed over 8 million times. She's written books. She has a new book coming out. She's written for Harvard Business Review, Forbes. There's just so much that she's done. And she is a fellow Australian. Julia Dahl, welcome to the psychology of your 20s.
杰玛，谢谢你邀请我。我太兴奋了。好吧，我总是这样，一上来就直接抛出一个问题。不过，我需要问的第一个问题是：你是谁？能给我们简单介绍一下你自己吗？我知道我刚才已经念过你的简历了，但用你自己的话来说，你是谁？好吧，现在你不仅知道我来自哪里，你的观众和听众也都知道了。我是在澳大利亚长大的。
Gemma, thanks for having me. I'm so excited. Well, okay, I always do this where I just jump into a question. And the first question I need to ask, though, is who are you? Can you tell us a little bit about yourself? I know I did, like, the resume rundown, but in your own words, who are you? Well, you know exactly where I'm from now, and now so do your viewers and listeners. I grew up in Australia.
关于我，有一件很重要的事情需要知道，那就是我在拜伦湾出生、后来搬到堪培拉之后，我成了一名辩论员。我曾经是个辩论特长生。你可能知道这一点，但对于任何没有把竞技辩论当回事的人来说，我们的桌面上通常会有一个重大主题或重大问题。这个议题有两个立场。一个团队赞成它。另一个团队反对它。
And one of the important things to know about me is after I was born in Byron Bay and then moved to Canberra, I became a debater. I was a debate kid. And so you might know this, but for anyone who doesn't think about competitive debate as we have a big topic or a big question on the table. There are two sides to the issue. One team talks for it. One team speaks against it.
双方你来我往，交流着这些观点。我把这作为起点来分享，是因为我认为那是我的开端，那是我第一次意识到：“哦，不同的人是不一样的。”通常情况下，面对同样的信息，人们会持有极其深刻的不同观点，或者表现出完全不同的行为。我认为，在澳大利亚的很多教室里，这个起点实际上让我开始思考：作为人类，我们究竟是谁？比如，我们想要什么，我们想成为什么样的人？
And you go back and forth, exchanging these ideas. And I share that as a starting point to say, that's where I became, I think, that was the first moment where I said, oh, different people are different. Like often people believe really profoundly different things or behave totally differently in response to the same information. And I think that starting point in new, lots of classrooms in Australia, actually got me thinking about who are we really as people? Like, what do we want, what do we want to be?
太有趣了。所以从你十几岁的时候起，你就觉得：“人类的行为对我来说实在是太迷人了”？你是这个意思吗？是的。所以我们表达这一点的一种方式是“不同的人是不同的”。但另一种表达方式是“其他人真是太奇怪了”。是的。
That's so interesting. And so like from when you were a teenager, you were like, human behavior is just so fascinating to me. Is that what you're saying? Yeah. And so one of the ways we say it is different people are different. But another way to say it is other people are so weird. Yeah.
其他人怎么都这么古怪。你越是这样想，就会觉得：开始试着去理解他们，可能会是一件非常有趣且相当有帮助的事情。后来我上了大学，最终来到美国读研究生时，我便一次又一次地琢磨这个问题：其他人到底是怎么回事？是的。当然，那些对自己说“其他人到底是怎么回事”的人，通常他们内心还有别的事情在发生。他们真正想表达的是：我到底是怎么回事？我是谁？我真正想要的是什么？我想我当时的情况就是这样。天哪，真的吗？是的。你，所以你去了悉尼大学？我当然去了。
Everyone else is so strange. And the more you say, it might be quite interesting, it might be quite helpful to start to understand them, which when I went to university and then eventually came to the United States to go to graduate school, I was scratching over and over again at this question of what is with other people. Yeah. And of course, people who are saying to themselves, what is with other people, there's usually something else going on there. What they really mean is, what's the deal with me? Who am I? What do I really want? And I think that was the case for me. Oh my God, really? Yeah. Did you, so you went to the University of Sydney? I sure did. Which is where I recently lived and have a fond place in my heart. What did you study at you, Sid? You studied economics and social science. The same as me. And I wrote my thesis, my undergraduate thesis on the economics of the luxury fashion industry. Like why do people buy? Why do people get attached emotionally to some brands and not others? And
那是我最近居住过并且在我的心中有着特殊地位的地方。你在悉尼大学学什么？你学的是经济学和社会学。和我一样。我写了我的毕业论文，我的本科毕业论文写的是奢侈时尚行业的经济学。比如，为什么人们会买奢侈品？为什么人们会对某些品牌产生情感依恋，而对另一些品牌不会？这在当时对我来说真的非常有意义。是的。你看起来很吃惊。不，我只是觉得……你把我的话匣子打开了。那我们就开始吧。哦，不。我当时想：“天哪，我完全可以扯得很远，比如问你关于这方面的好多问题，因为……”
that feel really, really meaningful to me at the time. Yeah. You look surprised. No, I'm just like that. You've set me off. Let's do it. Oh, no. I was like, oh, I could just go on like such a tangent of like asking you about this because
我们刚刚做了所有这些关于个人风格心理学和微潮流的节目。我最近一直在阅读大量关于时尚心理学的文章。你知道“具身认知”吗？我知道。我保证这只是一个小插曲。好吧。我知道。但你得把这个概念告诉其他人。
we've just done like all these episodes on like the psychology of personal style and microtrends. And I've been reading so much about fashion psychology recently. Do you know about enclosed cognition? I do. I promise to make this a small tangent. Okay. I do. But you have to tell everybody else about about it.
我们最近在一期节目中讨论过这个概念，基本上就是你穿的衣服实际上会影响你的情绪。完全正确。具身认知是其中一个微小的心理学概念，理解它的最好方式就是：你的穿着会影响你的思维方式。所以不仅是别人怎么看你，还有你自己是如何思考的。因此，换个角度来想，也许如果我穿着一套非常正式的西装，这可能会引导我在思考时更有条理、或者更严谨。如果我穿得很休闲，也许这会让我更有创造力、更开放、思维更开阔。这有没有改变你的穿着决定？
We've talked about it on a recent episode, basically how what you wear actually influences. your emotions. Exactly right. Includes cognition is one of these tiny psychological concepts, and the best way to understand it is what you wear influences how you think. So not just what do other people think about you, but how you think. And so one way to think about it is perhaps if I'm wearing a very formal suits that might lead me to be more structured in my thinking, for example, or more rigorous. If I'm dressed really casually, perhaps that makes me more creative, more open, more expansive. Did it change where you decided to wear?
嗯，我其实正在看我们的穿搭，而在 Netflix 上观看节目的观众会发现，我们基本上穿着几乎一模一样的衣服。确实如此。我当时想……我看到你走进来时，就在想：真是绝佳的选择。但我当时想，这太有趣了，因为显然我们俩已经从情感上为这场对话做好了准备。哦，这真不错。
Well, I'm actually looking at our outfits and people who are watching on Netflix we'll see we're basically wearing a version of the exact same outfit. It is true. I thought that did it. I saw you walk in and I was like, great choices. But I'm like, that's so interesting because obviously we're set, we've like emotionally set up for the same conversation. Oh, which is nice.
真有默契。我喜欢这样。我们都穿了一种非常清新、挺括的白色上衣，但又不会显得过于正式。一条得体的休闲裤，既舒适又可爱。然后是很有创意的鞋子。字面意义上富有创意且有趣的鞋子。哦，我们准备好开始啦。
Narching. I love that. I'm like, we've got a nice, a nice crisp kind of nice white top, but not like overly formal. A nice slacks situation, but like comfy. and then cute. Creative shoes. Literally creative fun shoes. Oh, we're ready to do this.
天哪。等等，我能再问你一个关于你的毕业论文的问题吗？请问。当你有某个发现时，或者当你得出某个结论时，那个让你欲罢不能、恨不得到处告诉别人的点是什么？关于人们为什么买奢侈品，或者我们为什么会做出某种时尚或购买选择？我认为关键在于，那些选择购买奢侈品或选择某个品牌而非另一个品牌的人，并不是因为他们对这个品牌感到了某种连接。
Oh my gosh. Wait, can I ask you one more question about your thesis that you did? Please. What was like the most, the thing that when you found out or when you discovered, you just couldn't stop telling people about why people buy luxury or why we make certain fashion or purchasing choices? I think the thing is that people who choose to buy luxury goods or to buy one brand over another, it's not because they feel a connection with the brand.
而是因为拥有它——拥有那件东西，是他们自我的一部分。而你知道这一点的方法之一就是——你生命中的某些人，例如，他们可能会购买奢侈时尚品却从来不穿。但他们拥有它，而且他们知道自己拥有它。所以这感觉非常像是他们身份的一部分，是他们作为一个人的本质的一部分，或者是他们与外界建立联系的方式……我知道他们是如何与世界联系的。哦，天哪。你看，我有个朋友就是这样，她去年给自己买了一个非常漂亮的包。她工作非常努力。我问过她
It is because having it, owning the thing, is a part of who they are. And one of the ways you know that is, and people in your life who, for example, might buy luxury fashion and never wear it. But they have it and they know that they have it. And so it feels very much like a part of their identity, part of who they are as a person or how they relate to one I'll know how they relate to the world. Oh my goodness. See, I have a friend who's like this who, and she bought this, like, beautiful bag for herself last year. She works so hard. And I asked
前几天，我问她：“你为什么从来不把那个包拿出来用？”她说：“呃，这有点太高调了。”但我觉得对她来说，情况是这样的：“好吧，我已经达到了这样一个阶段，这是女性或我认识的人眼中的成功标志。所以我必须参与其中，但这又感觉与我更深层的身份相悖。”这太迷人了。这不太像我自己。这太有趣了。还有，我正在考虑
her the other day, I was like, why do you never bring that out? She's like, what's a bit too flashy? But I feel like it for her, it was like, well, I've gotten to this point where this is like a marker of success for women or the people that I know. So I have to participate, but then it also feels like contrary to my deeper identity. This is so fascinating. It's not quite me. That's so interesting. Also, I'm like thinking. about what I'm wearing, then I need to move on. Like, you can see, and I'm wearing like all one brand. And when you were saying that, I was like, oh my gosh, I just thought I really liked that. I'm that person. Yeah, but maybe it's what they represent. Could be. Wow. Okay. Let's actually
我身上穿的衣服，然后我觉得我得往下聊了。你看，我身上穿的全是一个品牌。当你说到这里时，我当时就在想：“天哪，我以前以为我真的很喜欢那个牌子。我就是那种人。”是的，但也许这代表了它们所象征的东西。有可能。哇。好吧。让我们来谈谈
talk about what we, what I've brought you to discuss. What we came here to talk about. Which is not, which we need to bring you back to just talk about fashion psychology. Anytime. Let's talk about bad habits and where bad habits come from. A good starting point might be to say there are no bad habits, or perhaps it's not very helpful to call something a bad habit and just condemn it right off the bat. Of course, there are habits that are more or less destructive or damaging to our health or our relationships or the way we show up in the world. But even then just saying this is a bad habit is maybe not very helpful.
我们为什么……我邀请你来讨论的话题。我们今天来这里要谈的话题。其实我们可以随时请你回来专门聊聊时尚心理学。随时奉陪。让我们来聊聊坏习惯以及坏习惯的根源。一个很好的切入点也许是：其实并没有所谓的坏习惯，或者说，把某种行为直接斥为坏习惯并对其进行全盘否定，其实并没有什么帮助。当然，有些习惯或多或少具有毁灭性，会对我们的健康、人际关系或我们在世界上的表现造成破坏。即便如此，仅仅说“这是一个坏习惯”也许并没有太大帮助。
But what we can assume when someone says, I have a bad habit, beeping, not eating as healthily as I would like, not exercising as often as I might want to. What they mean is there is something about the way I operate that I want to change. So where do they come from? One of my favorite things about the work that I do is I spend a lot of time talking to people about changing, so not just change, but how do I get better at changing? And part of it is we're not totally sure psychologically about change. People have really different reactions when you say, do you want to change?
但当有人说“我有一个坏习惯：抽电子烟、饮食不够健康、锻炼不够频繁”时，我们可以推断出的是：我的运作方式中有些东西是我想要改变的。那么它们是从哪里来的呢？我从事这项工作最喜欢的一点是，我花了很多时间与人们谈论改变，不仅是关于改变，还有如何让自己更擅长改变。部分原因在于，我们在心理上并不完全确当我们说“你想要改变吗”时，人们会有截然不同的反应。
If you say to someone, would you like to be better? Almost everyone says, yeah, that's what I'm here to do. I'm trying to be better. So what's preventing us? What's getting in the way of us actually being better? There are basically three things. And they are environmental, tactical, and relational. So an environmental cause of a bad habit might be something really.
如果你对某人说：“你想变得更好吗？”几乎所有人都会说：“废话，我来这儿就是为了这个。我一直在努力变好。”那么是什么在阻止我们呢？是什么挡在我们真正变好的路上？基本上有三个因素。它们分别是：环境因素、策略因素和关系因素。因此，坏习惯的环境原因可能非常基础。
basic. Like, I live very far away from a place where I could safely exercise. I don't have good quality access to healthy food that's affordable. A relational one might be I have a set of friends who, when I go out with them, the night kind of spins out of control. Very good example of a relational one. And a tactical one might be, I just haven't set myself up in quite the right way. And so Katie Milkman at Warden, the University of Pennsylvania, has a great set of research on how do we create the tactical conditions for us to be healthier, be better versions of ourselves. And the most basic version of it is, do I put my gym shoes, do I put my trainers by the door before I go to bed at night? So then when I wake up, it's like, whoa, my sneakers are right there. I don't have to look around for all of the clothes, shoes I need in order to go and exercise.
比如，我住的地方离一个可以安全锻炼的场所非常远。我无法以负担得起的价格获得优质的健康食品。而关系因素可能是：我有一群朋友，每当我跟他们出去时，夜晚往往会变得一发不可收拾。这是一个非常典型的关系因素的例子。至于策略因素，可能是：我没有以完全正确的方式做好准备。因此，宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的凯蒂·米尔克曼（Katie Milkman）做过一系列非常棒的研究，探讨我们如何为自己变得更健康、成为更好的自己创造策略条件。最基础的版本就是：我有没有在晚上睡觉前把运动鞋放在门边？这样当我醒来时，就会觉得：“哇，我的运动鞋就在那里。”我不必为了去锻炼而到处找我需要的衣服和鞋子。
So I've created the right tactics for that to happen. Where someone has a habit that they are seeking to change, part of it is saying, like, let's diagnose what's really going wrong here. Have I got an environmental gap? Do I have a relational gap or a set of relationships that are maybe taking me to places that I don't necessarily want to go? Or do I just not have the right tactics? I want to read more, but I never have a book handy.
所以我为此制定了正确的策略。当一个人有了想要改变的习惯时，部分工作就是：让我们诊断一下这里究竟出了什么问题。我是否存在环境上的缺失？我是否存在人际关系上的缺失，或者有一群人际关系在不知不觉中把我带向了我未必想去的地方？或者我只是缺乏正确的策略？我想多读书，但我手头从来没有书。
I want to exercise more, but it seems like my clothes. are always in the laundry. These are things we can change relatively quickly. I love this way of thinking about it. When does it become a motivational problem? And when does it become maybe something bigger than all those things that like environment, tactics, you know, people can't change? I think one of the really dangerous things that can come from spending a lot of time thinking about your own psychology is assuming that anytime you don't live up to your own expectations, that's a problem of discipline or motivation. I'm just not disciplined enough. I'm too lazy to be able to do the thing that I want to do. And if instead you said to yourself,
我想多锻炼，但我的衣服似乎永远都在洗衣机里。这些都是我们可以相对较快地改变的事情。我非常喜欢这种思考方式。什么时候它会变成一个动机问题？而什么时候它又会变成比所有这些因素（比如环境、策略、人们无法改变的因素）更大的问题呢？我认为，花大量时间思考自己的心理可能会带来的最危险的事情之一，就是假设每当你不符合自己的期望时，那就是自律或动机出了问题。我只是不够自律。我太懒了，所以做不到我想做的事。而如果你转而对自己说：
look, discipline and motivation, these are really finite. Psychologists would say they're cognitively very expensive to maintain. It takes a lot of effort to keep us. To keep us. goals and objectives at the very front of our mind. And so if we can push ourselves a little bit beyond that and instead say what we should actually be trying to build all of the time is self-efficacy. And I continue to think that self-efficacy is just one of the most underloved concepts in all of psychology. And you, of course, know this, but if anyone needed a quick definition, self-efficacy is basically your belief in your own capabilities, that if an obstacle comes up, your level of confidence that you will figure out a way around it that you already have
“听着，自律和动机，这些东西其实非常有限。”心理学家会说，在认知上维持它们的成本很高。要让我们的目标和客观规划始终保持在脑海最显眼的位置，需要付出巨大的努力。因此，如果我们能稍微超越这一点，转而思考我们实际上应该一直努力培养的是什么——那就是自我效能感。我一直认为，自我效能感是整个心理学中最被低估的概念之一。你当然知道这一点，但如果有人需要一个简短的定义，自我效能感基本上就是你对自己能力的信念：当障碍出现时，你对自己有能力找到解决办法的信心水平，即你已经具备
or could quickly acquire the resources and to solve it. Are you a Ted Lassau viewer? Are you my favorite person? Yes, of course I am a Ted Lassow viewer. I have a multi-watch viewer. Have you watched? Wait, sorry, no. Yes, talk to me about Ted Lassau.
或者可以快速获取解决问题所需的资源。你看过《足球教练》（Ted Lasso）吗？你是我的最爱吗？是的，我当然看过《足球教练》。我反复刷过好几遍。你看过吗？等等，抱歉，没有。是的，跟我聊聊《足球教练》吧。
So in the very first season of Ted Lassau, there's a great line where Rebecca says to Ted, do you believe in ghosts, Ted? And he says, you know, I do. But most of all, I just want them to believe in themselves. And I think that's what self-efficacy is. It's people believing in themselves, but also being surrounded by people who want them to believe in themselves. And so if instead of saying, oh, I'm too lazy, I'm not disciplined enough, you can say,
所以在《足球教练》的第一季里有一句非常棒的台词，丽贝卡对泰德说：“泰德，你相信有鬼吗？”泰德说：“你知道吗？我是相信的。但最重要的是，我只是希望他们相信自己。”我想这就是自我效能感的意义所在。它是人们相信自己，同时也身处那些希望他们相信自己的人群之中。因此，与其说“哦，我太懒了，我不够自律”，你可以反问自己：
do I actually have the self-ethicacy that I need? And you can also increase your own self-ethicacy just by thinking about it. The example I always think of with self-efficacy is somebody who's trying to quit drinking, right? And if you go into the pub or you go into the bar and you already are thinking, well, if I want to have a drink, I can't say no. Or like, will I be able to say no? Will I be able to not do that? Will I be able to cope with not drinking tonight? and you don't have any backup plan, you have no belief that you'll be able to, like, you've
“我真的具备我所需的自我效能感吗？”而且你仅仅通过思考就能提升自己的自我效能感。每当我想到自我效能感时，我脑海中浮现的例子就是那些试图戒酒的人，对吧？如果你走进一家酒馆或酒吧，心里就已经在想：“如果我想喝一杯，我是绝对拒绝不了的”；或者“我能拒绝吗？”“我能克制住不喝吗？”“今晚我不喝酒，我能应付得过去吗？”而且你没有任何备用计划，你根本不相信自己能够做到——这就好像你
kind of already lost. And that's the same with any kind of behavioral change, right? If you already are counting yourself out, if you're already like letting kind of doubt seep in, I think that shows that like self-efficacy kind of needs strengthening. It needs a boost. And you've, as soon as you've started this negotiation with yourself, exactly, perhaps I will just have one or I'll wait for someone to ask me, you're not taking a second to remind yourself, you know, I've done a lot of difficult things before. I have overcome a lot of obstacles before. And if I can spend a moment bringing those to the forefront of my mind,
其实已经输了。任何类型的行为改变都是如此，对吧？如果你已经开始自我否定，如果你的内心已经开始滋生怀疑，我认为这表明你的自我效能感需要得到加强。它需要一次提升。而一旦你开始与自己进行这种内心的拉锯战——“也许我只喝一杯就好”或者“我等别人来劝我”，你其实并没有花哪怕一秒钟来提醒自己：“你知道吗？我以前做过很多困难的事。我以前克服过很多障碍。只要我花一点时间把这些经历带到脑海的最前沿，
perhaps even writing them down or talking to someone about them, both of which we know make a really big difference in your goal attainment, even if I can just remind myself mentally, I've overcome very difficult things before. Our chance of success goes way up. I love that. We talk about that a lot of like, I think you actually talk about it in your book of like setting, was it like an early win?
甚至把它们写下来或者跟别人聊聊——我们都知道这会对你达成目标产生巨大的影响——哪怕我只是在心里提醒自己：我以前克服过非常艰难的事情。”我们成功的几率就会大幅上升。我太喜欢这个了。我们经常讨论这一点，我想你其实也在你的书中讨论过，比如设定……是不是类似“早期胜利”的东西？
Exactly. And the idea that you can, in very positive ways, trick yourself into change, is extremely compelling to me. And a couple of really easy tricks. One is just reminding yourself of hard things that you have done before. Or, for example, we're thinking about how might exercise much more regularly. Let's say that you have got, you're still in your home and you've got as far as putting your shoes on, even just saying to yourself, well, I'm 20% of the way there now. Like, I've got my shoes on.
正是如此。你可以通过非常积极的方式在心理上“哄骗”自己做出改变，这对我来说具有极大的吸引力。这里有几个非常简单的诀窍。其中一个是提醒自己以前做过哪些艰难的事情。或者，举个例子，假设我们在思考如何能够更规律地进行锻炼。假设你还待在家里，并且已经做到了把运动鞋穿好这一步，哪怕只是对自己说：“好吧，我现在已经完成了 20%。你看，我已经穿好鞋子了。
I've got a podcast queued up. I'm about to walk out the door. And basically, more or less done. We call that the endowed progress effect. You have an amount of progress that you've already achieved. All of these actually are just the tiniest of little nudges that move you towards becoming the person you want to be. Yeah, I love these.
我已经调好了一个播客。我正准备走出家门。”基本上，这事儿差不多算成了。我们称之为“赋予进展效应”（endowed progress effect）。你已经取得了一定程度的进展。所有这一切，实际上都只是微乎其微的小推动力，它们一步步推动你成为你想成为的那个人。是的，我很喜欢这些。
I really want to talk about those in a second, a little bit more. But something that I've obviously skipped over is why do we even end up in these places? Why do we end up with a habit that is making us unhappy and making us suffer? Whether that is like, why do I end up in the habit of being with people who aren't nice to me, even though I know the outcome? Why do I end up in the habit of drinking too much even though I know I feel bad or, you know, not committing to things even though I know that they're going to make me feel better? Can you kind of explain how we end up at this point where we know we need behavioral change,
我真的很想稍后再深入探讨一下这些。但有一个我显然跳过了的问题是：我们为什么最终会陷入这些困境？为什么我们最终会落入一个让我们不开心、让我们痛苦的习惯中？无论是“为什么我会陷入一段与对我不好的人在一起的习惯中，尽管我知道结果会怎样？”“为什么我会陷入酗酒的习惯，尽管我知道自己会感觉糟糕？”或者“为什么我明知做这些事会让我感觉更好，却始终无法承诺去做？”你能解释一下，我们是如何走到这一步的吗？在这个阶段，我们明知自己需要改变行为，
but now we're struggling to do it. And then you get by yourself for a second and you say, what is wrong with me? Yeah, exactly. And then you kind of ask yourself, what is wrong with me? And you say, well, I don't actually don't really know. Like, I don't have good explanations, but I know I don't want to be and where I am.
却又在苦苦挣扎，然后你独自一呆，就会对自己说：“我到底怎么了？”是的， exatamente。然后你会反问自己：“我到底怎么了？”你会说：“好吧，其实我真的不知道。我没有好的解释，但我知道我不想呆在现在这个地方，也不想变成现在这样。”
So we have some good thoughts about why it might be the case. A really important one is identity salience. So we all wear so many hats, so many versions of ourselves. we are different at work than we are at home. We're different with some friends than we are others. And you can think about these as not totally different people, but they're different versions of Julia, different versions of Gemma that people experience.
所以，对于为什么会出现这种情况，我们有一些不错的见解。其中一个非常重要的因素就是“身份显著性”（identity salience）。我们所有人都扮演着许多不同的角色，展现着自我的许多不同版本。我们在工作中和在家里的状态是不同的。我们在某些朋友面前和在其他人面前也是不同的。你可以把这些看作并非完全不同的人，而是朱莉娅的不同版本，是人们所体验到的不同版本的杰玛。
And that's normal. It can be really healthy. But often when we find ourselves in a situation or a relationship or an environment or a job, by the way, that we don't want to be in, it is because there is some part of our identity that that is, really important to us, even if we haven't properly excavated or understood it. Like, if I became single, I don't know who I would be, for example. Or I have only ever had this job. So it is impossible for me to imagine having another one. So I can't quit. So I stay trapped in a job that I
这很正常。这甚至可能非常健康。但通常情况下，当我们发现自己陷入某种处境、某种关系、某种环境，或者顺便说一句，陷入某种我们其实并不想呆的工作中时，那是因为我们的身份中有一部分对我们来说真的非常重要，哪怕我们还没有真正去发掘或理解它。比如：“如果我单身了，我都不知道自己会是谁。”或者：“我一辈子只干过这一份工作。所以我根本无法想象自己换一份工作。”因此我无法辞职。于是我被困在了一份
know makes me unhappy, for example. And so really doing two things. One is press yourself. So what's the part of my identity that is really coming to the forefront here, including I'm part of this friend group. And if, for example, I didn't go out with this friend group on a certain night, maybe there would never be my friends again. And then I would never have any more friends for the rest of my life. So one is pressed, like, what's the part of our identity that we're really protecting?
明知会让自己不快乐的工作中，比如这样。所以真正要做的有两件事。第一件事是逼问自己：在这个情境中，究竟哪一部分身份正在真正凸显出来？包括“我是这个朋友圈子的一部分”。如果我比如在某天晚上没有和这个朋友圈子一起出去，也许他们就再也不是我的朋友了。然后我这辈子就再也没有朋友了。所以第一点是逼问自己：我们究竟在守护身份的哪一部分？
And how true is that? Is it possible that I could not be happy as a single person? Is it possible that there's any other job in the universe that might be meaningful or satisfying to me? And then the second is actually to look back a little bit. We call this in psychology the end of history illusion. Daniel Gilbert and others at Harvard University pioneered this, which is it's difficult for us to imagine that we will change a lot in the future for most of us. We think this is a finished product.
而这究竟有多大程度是真的？难道我作为一个单身的人就绝对不会快乐吗？难道宇宙中真的没有其他任何一份对我而言有意义或能让我感到满足的工作了吗？第二点其实是往回看一看。我们在心理学中称之为“历史终结幻觉”（endof history illusion）。丹尼尔·吉尔伯特（Daniel Gilbert）等哈佛大学的研究人员率先提出了这一点，即：我们很难想象自己在未来会发生很大的改变，对我们大多数人来说，我们觉得自己已经是一个成品了。
But if you ask us to look back, especially earlier in our lives, you say, well, I'm 26 now, if I look back until I, to the time when I was 16 and ask myself, am I different? You say, oh my gosh, I'm basically a different person in so many ways. And so I can also, it's actually likely that I'll be very different in the future. And so being able to do a little bit of that prospection and imagine that future Julia could be a totally different person. happy in a totally different set of circumstances and that by making some different choices now, we could actually be doing something very kind for that future version of ourselves, even if it's hard to do it for the present version of ourselves.
但如果你让我们回头看，尤其是回顾我们生命中更早的阶段，你会说：“好吧，我现在 26 岁了。如果我回顾到我 16 岁的时候，问自己：‘我和以前不一样了吗？’你会说：‘天哪，我在很多方面简直就像是换了一个人。’”因此，我在未来发生巨大改变其实也是很有可能的。所以，能够做一点这样的前瞻性思考，想象未来的朱莉娅可能会是一个完全不同的人，在完全不同的环境中感到快乐，并且通过现在做出一些不同的选择，我们其实是在为未来那个版本的自己做一件非常善良的事——哪怕对于当下的我们来说这很难做到。
Yeah, I love thinking that way, actually. I think about that a lot where I'm just like, wow, isn't it amazing that the time's going to pass anyways? And in one year, like a year in your 20s is like five years everywhere else. I do, I fully believe that. so much can change. I love what you said, though, by the way, which is the time is going to pass anyway. That's true. The time is going to pass anyway. Someone is going to get this opportunity that you may or may not raise your hand for. There's a set of relationships,
是的，我其实很喜欢这种思考方式。我经常这样想，我就在想：“哇，反正时间都会流逝，不是吗？”在二十几岁的时候，一年感觉就像其他地方的五年。我真的，我完全相信这一点。很多事情都会发生改变。不过，顺便说一句，我非常喜欢你刚才说的那句话，那就是：反正时间都会流逝。确实如此。反正时间都会流逝。总会有人抓住这个机会，而你可能会、也可能不会为此举手。有一系列的关系——
friendship, romantic, professional that are available to you, if you put yourself out there. The time is going to pass anyway. And so you might as well take a chance, take a chance, take a risk and the returns on that risk-taking in your 20s are so much higher than through the rest of your life. Yeah. Or like tomorrow, yeah, you may only have been eating healthy for 24 hours or you may only have not, you know, vaped or smoked for 24 hours, but then in three days it's going to be 72 hours. And then suddenly it's going to be six months. And it's like, well, the time is passing anyways. And like, all you have to do was be present in that moment and not or do the thing that you said you were going to do and you have this whole new life. So they're very interesting.
友情、爱情、职业上的关系——只要你勇敢走出去，它们都是为你准备的。反正时间都会流逝。所以你不如去碰碰运气，去抓住机会，去承担风险。而在你二十几岁的时候，承担这些风险的回报要比你一生中的其他任何时候都高得多。对啊。或者就像明天一样，也许你才刚刚坚持健康饮食 24 小时，或者你才刚刚戒掉电子烟或香烟 24 小时，但三天后，它就会变成 72 小时。然后转眼间，它就变成了六个月。你会发现：“好吧，反正时间都在流逝。而你所需要做的，就是活在当下，不要破戒，或者去做你答应过自己要做的事，然后你就拥有了全新的人生。”所以这非常有趣。
This is a question I, like, have highlighted on my question list that I really want to ask you. I am sure a lot of us have heard about the magic number that it takes 90 days to break a bad habit. This is a very, like, viral idea. Is that true? No. I don't know exactly how long it takes to break a habit. I feel very confident that the answer is not 90 days most of the time. And we can all.
这是一个我特别想问你的问题，它一直高亮在我的问题清单上。我确信我们很多人都听说过这样一个神奇的数字：戒掉一个坏习惯需要 90 天。这是一个非常病毒式的观点。这是真的吗？不是的。我不知道戒掉一个习惯具体需要多长时间。但我非常确信，大多数情况下答案绝对不是 90 天。我们都可以
all think about, and it's a really easy way to disprove this, which is we can all think of examples of a friend or a relative, perhaps ourselves, who one day says I have decided to quit smoking, for example, or quit drinking or take up exercising. And they somehow do, then for the rest of their life, that person doesn't do that thing anymore. And we can equally think about people at the opposite end of the spectrum, who, with a lot of advice with a lot of encouragement, are not able to change or evolve, maybe even with a lot of attempts to break a bad habit. There's good evidence that suggests that to really internalize
想到——而且有一个非常简单的方法可以推翻这个说法——我们都可以想到这样的例子：某个朋友、亲戚，或者可能就是我们自己，有一天突然说：“我决定戒烟了，”或者“我决定戒酒，”或者“我决定开始锻炼。”他们不知怎么就做到了，然后余下的一生中，这个人再也没有碰过那个东西。我们同样可以想到光谱另一端的人：他们听取了大量建议，得到了大量鼓励，却依然无法改变或进化，甚至可能尝试了无数次去戒掉一个坏习惯。有充分的证据表明，要在你的脑海中真正内化
a new habit in your mind can take anywhere from between four and about 255 days, which is obviously a really wide spectrum in terms of creating and establishing new neural pathways in your brain so that whatever the behavior is becomes automatic. There are for sure things we can do to make it easier because I could imagine people saying, I'd like it to take four days rather than 256 days. I'm with you. I know, you're like, I'd like the four days. Can I choose that first option?
一个新习惯，时间可能短至 4 天，长达大约 255 天。显然，在你的大脑中创造和建立新的神经通路，使无论什么行为变成自动化行为，这是一个跨度极大的区间。当然，我们确实可以做一些事情来让这个过程变得更容易，因为我可以想象有人会说：“我宁愿花 4 天而不是 256 天。”我懂你。我知道，你会想：“我选四天。
Do we get to pick how many days and if so, four? I'd like it to take four days. Things you can do to bring yourself closer to four days rather than 256 days. Number one, you can write it down. Number two, you can tell somebody else about. it. So that's clearly articulate your goal. You can make it visible and social to people. And you can shift your environment, shift the context in which you operate to make it less likely that the habit is available or attractive to you as well. So this is the other thing I feel like is the
我们能自己挑天数吗？如果可以，我要四天。”你可以做一些事情，让自己更接近 4 天而不是 256 天。第一，你可以把它写下来。第二，你可以把它告诉别人。也就是说，清晰地表达你的目标。你可以让它变得对别人可见、具有社交属性。你可以改变你的环境、改变你运作的语境，从而降低这个习惯对你的可及性或诱惑力。这也是我觉得
problem with the 90 day thing. And I wonder if you have the same thought, which is it takes 90 days to break a bad habit. But once you're past that, if you keep the habit for the rest of your life, who's to say it didn't take one day? Then what happens? Do you know what I mean? Exactly. So it's like, it's like, well, if I go back to smoking or whatever on day 100, you know what I mean? Like, it doesn't make sense because if you've set the new habit, surely it lasts forever. Like, do you know what I'm saying? I know exactly what you're saying. And it's such a good point because if we think about it for even a second and this is why it's so important, I think, for you to do exactly what you do and help people like really unpack, like the science behind
关于 90 天说法的另一个问题所在。我在想你是不是也有同感：那就是“戒掉一个坏习惯需要 90 天”。但一旦你过了这个期限，如果你在余生中一直保持这个习惯，谁能说它不是只花了一天呢？那接下来会发生什么呢？你知道我的意思吗？完全没错。所以这就变成：“好吧，如果我在第 100 天又开始抽烟了……”你知道我的意思吗？这根本说不通，因为如果你已经养成了新习惯，它肯定会永远持续下去。你不觉得吗？我完全明白你的意思。而且这真的很有道理，因为如果我们哪怕思考一秒钟就会发现——这也是为什么我认为你做的事情如此重要：你帮助大家真正剖析了
this psychology. You pause and think about it for a second C. Is that likely? Like, is it likely that for everyone 90 days is the magic number? Of course it's not likely. Is it even a helpful guide? Not really. And instead, what we should be perhaps encouraging people to think about is the idea that instead of saying, I have changed, what I basically is, what I basically is, always doing is changing. Like I'm always evolving and hopefully moving towards something more positive. It's very hard to run away from something negative for the rest of your life. But if we can continue to say, all I'm trying to do is make a set of better and better, kinder and kinder to myself and to others choices, then every single day I get the chance to make the choice again. And hopefully that
背后的科学原理以及这种心理学。你停下来思考一秒钟：“C，这合理吗？对每个人来说，90 天真的是个神奇的数字吗？”这当然不合理。它甚至是一个有用的指南吗？其实并不是。相反，我们也许应该鼓励人们去思考这样一个概念：与其说“我已经改变了”，不如说“我其实一直在改变”。就像我一直在进化，并且希望朝着更积极的方向前进。要在一生中逃避某种消极的东西是非常困难的。但如果我们能不断告诉自己：“我所做的，只是不断做出越来越好、对自我和他人越来越仁慈的选择，”那么每一天，我都有机会重新做出这个选择。希望这
feels really positive rather than exhausting to people of, oh, we're going to get up and decide not to smoke again. I'm going to get up and go out and decide how I'm going to show up in this night. But instead, say, let's take you one step at a time. We're always in the process of becoming who we are. I actually think that is such a smart way of thinking about it, which is stop thinking about changing habits as deprivation, but instead as addition. And I think they've done amazing, amazing studies where it is so much easier to, it's so much harder to say, don't eat the marshmallow or don't do the thing than say, but opt into doing something, opt in to like do this activity instead of eating the marshmallow or like think about the
对人们来说是一种积极的体验，而不是一种筋疲力尽的折磨——“哦，我又得起床决定不抽烟了”，“我要起床出门，决定今晚该怎么表现”。相反，我们应该对自己说：“让我们一步一个脚印。我们永远都在成为自己的过程中。”其实我真的觉得这是一种非常聪明的思考方式，那就是：不要把改变习惯看作是一种剥夺，而应该看作是一种增加。而且我想他们做过非常了不起的研究：比起对某人说“别吃那块棉花糖”或者“别做那件事”，要容易得多的是——但同时去主动选择做别的事。主动选择去做某种活动，而不是去吃那块棉花糖；或者把习惯、把行为改变看作是一份礼物，或者是为你的人生做加法，而不是仅仅想着：“哦，我必须花一辈子时间不喝酒。我必须花一辈子时间不吃碳水化合物。”——好吧，这是一个糟糕的习惯例子。但我的意思是，“我必须花一辈子时间剥夺自己的某些东西才能快乐。”其实也可以是：“或者你余下的人生都可以去享受……”
habit or think about behavioral change as something that is like a gift or an addition to your life rather than just like, oh, I have to spend the rest of my life not drinking. I have to spend the rest of my life not eating carbs. So that's a terrible habit example. But like I have to spend the rest of my life depriving myself of something in order to be happy. It's like, or you get to spend the rest of your life. You know, oh, today's a day I get to wake up and like my lungs feel even better. Today's a day that I get to wake up and try a new mocktail.
“哦，今天是新的一天，我醒来时感觉肺部更舒服了。今天是新的一天，我可以醒来尝试一杯无酒精鸡尾酒。”“今天是新的一天，我可以醒来，以一种感觉如此丰盛的方式真正滋养我的身体。”我觉得这真是一种非常棒的行为转变。这正是你刚才所表达的意思，对吧？我喜欢这种内心的自我辩论——不过，这是一个非常积极的问题形式，比如：“这对究竟我有什么好处？”“对我到底有什么好处？我为什么要这么做？”你越是能开始对自己说：“哦，我明白了这对我的好处……”
Today's the day I get to wake up and like really nourish my body in like a way that feels so fruitful. I feel like that's such a good behavioral shift. And that's what I'm hearing you kind of say, right? I like the idea of having a inner debate with yourself. but the really positive form of the question is, like, what's in it for me? Like, what's in it for me? Why would I even do this? And the more you can start to say to yourself, oh, like, I know what's in it for me.
今天是新的一天，我可以醒来，真正以一种感觉非常富有成效的方式滋养我的身体。我觉得这是一个很好的行为转变。这就是我听到的你所表达的意思，对吧？我喜欢和自己进行内心辩论的想法，但这个问题的真正积极形式是，对我有何益处？比如，对我有什么好处？我为什么要这么做？当你越来越开始对自己说，哦，我知道这对有什么好处时。
And it is all those examples that you just gave and probably many more for people. You get to remind yourself that there are benefits that are coming. Even better is if you can remind yourself of benefits that are here already. And I've saved money. I got to have a conversation with someone that I'm trying to repair a relationship with, for example. I tried a workout dance class and fell down, but I also fell down in front of a lot of people and I did not die of embarrassment.
通过你刚才给出的所有这些例子，可能还有更多其他人的例子，你可以提醒自己，未来的好处还在后头。更好的是，如果你能提醒自己已经得到了那些好处。比如，我省了钱。我能跟一个我正试图修复关系的人谈心。我尝试了一节健身舞蹈课，虽然摔倒了，但我也在很多人面前摔倒了，而且我并没有尴尬得死掉。
Like I have learned something new and positive about myself. So there are not only benefits that are coming in the future, which is good but still hard for us to imagine, but I'm getting benefits right now. I love that. What's in it for me? what's in it for me? Like if you want to change your behavior, you'd be like, what am I going to gain tomorrow? And again, like we were talking about that small win, like setting yourself up to
就像我学到了一些关于自己的新的积极的东西。因此，不仅有将要到来的未来的好处——这很好，但我们仍然很难想象，而且我现在就得到了好处。我太喜欢这样了。对我有什么好处？对我有什么好处？就像如果你想改变你的行为，你可能会想，我明天能得到什么？再者，就像我们之前讨论的那种小胜利，比如为自己设定一个目标
win big or at least small, but it wins something like really, really early on. Pride is like love. You feel it in your heart. IR. Radio. Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts, including IHart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must have party bangers, plus personalized and curated playlists. Like back in the Day Pride. Come together, celebrate love. Take pride with you. Anytime, anywhere.
赢得大奖，或者至少是小奖，但在很早很早的时候就赢得一些东西。自豪就像爱。你能在心中感受到它。iHeart Radio。加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用，包括iHeart Pride Canada、你最喜欢的金曲和派对必听神曲，以及个性化和精心策划的播放列表。就像当年的骄傲节一样。欢聚一堂，庆祝爱。随时随地，保持自豪。
Just ask your smart speaker to play IHart Pride Canada. Stream us on your phone. Or listen now at iHeartRadio.ca. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black.
只需让你的智能音箱播放iHeart Pride Canada。在手机上收听我们。或者现在就登录iHeartRadio.ca收听。当时，感觉就像过了一个世纪。我以为我活不成了。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里空洞得没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。
It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape and murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so.
这把我吓死了。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，长官。针对儿童的强奸和谋杀。再糟糕不过了。我想是这样的。
Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
恶魔，醒醒。我就是那个目睹克里瓦奇和德皮波行凶的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得无动于衷。我说我没有罪。我要把这带进棺材里。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《恶魔的采石场》。
And to hear The Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression.
想要无广告收听《恶魔的采石场》并获取独家内容，请在苹果播客上订阅Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《与霍达·科特比一起探索快乐101》的主持人。在这里，我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话，比如当女演员奥利维娅·芒分享她是如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更加困难。有很多人理解产后抑郁症。
I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And it's a part of it's because their new star is Javier T. Turrito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions. ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions.
但我对产后焦虑毫无准备。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《与霍达·科特比一起探索快乐101》。部分原因是因为他们的新星是哈维尔·T·奇恰里托·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我当成一个足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，我是个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存。自从我出生以来。我依然有这么多的疑问。
Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary.
我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何应对被取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？从日常的平凡到深邃的不凡。
This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. This life has an order perfect and everything is good. We are here to connect. We are here to connect.
这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深度交谈，脆弱感在这里流露。阴谋论被摆上台面，目标和人生经验得以分享。生命本身有着完美的秩序，一切皆好。我们来到这里是为了连接。我们来到这里是为了连接。
The Chicharito. Oh, Javier, Ticharro-R-Nandes, and together with Aihar Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Wow. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is,
小豌豆。哦，哈维尔·奇恰里托·埃尔南德斯，与iHeart Radio一起，我们要将平凡化为不凡。请持续关注。真是个球星。在iHeart Radio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。有些事本不该如此复杂，
getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier. easier than it is. Getting a new one put up in its place. As long as there's a politics of race in America, there's going to be a politics of remembering the Civil War. To get to school, I had to go down Robert Lee Boulevard. Get to the grocery store, I had to go down Jefferson Davis Parkway. If you're an historian and you leave out half of what the history is, you're not doing your job. I'm Akila Hughes. In Rebel Spirit, season two goes deep on both of those things. The fights, the politics, the people who won, and my personal campaign to add
比如移除一座种族主义雕像。而另有一件事本应该容易得多。比实际情况要容易得多。取而代之的是竖起一座新雕像。只要美国还存在种族政治，就会存在纪念内战的政治。为了去学校，我不得不走罗伯特·李大道。去杂货店，我不得不走杰斐逊·达维斯公园大道。如果你是一位历史学家，却漏掉了历史的一半，那你就是在失职。我是阿基拉·休斯。在《反叛精神》第二季中，我们将深入探讨这两件事。斗争、政治、胜利者，以及我个人的抗争，我要在
something to the Kentucky State House that's actually worth the wall space. We are more than our bodies. We contain essence. We contain spirit. How do you represent that? They are just fueling a fire that is really catching. You'll see what I mean. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I want to just quickly go back to one thing that we, again, I keep, I keep like wanting to pick your brain about all these things. Why does motivation and discipline, but mainly I would say actually, why does motivation fail us so often? And why is it that people who have all the motivation in the world are often the ones who don't always, that aren't always successful? because motivation without both a really good plan, the right support and the right environment
肯塔基州议会大厦里增加一些真正值得占据一面墙的东西。我们不仅仅是我们的肉体。我们包含着本质。我们包含着精神。你如何体现这一点？他们只是在火上浇油，而这团火正燃得越来越旺。你会明白我的意思的。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《反叛精神》第二季。我想快速回到一件事上，我们——再次说明，我一直、一直想就所有这些事情向你请教。为什么动力和纪律——但我主要想说的是，为什么动力总是让我们失望？为什么那些拥有世上全部动力的人，往往却不是那些总是、并不总是成功的人呢？因为缺乏一个真正优秀的计划、正确的支持和正确的环境的动力
is just too much effort. You are basically constantly pushing against a brick wall. And so it is a way of trapping you in your own good intentions. And that's so unfortunate because people really deserve a chance to take all, of the wisdom from psychology, from behavioral science, from neuroscience, and use it to their own advantage. And if we just say to people, oh, I think you need a little bit more motivation, it's like saying to people don't get defensive. It's going to produce the exact opposite of the behavior that you hope it will. And so when you feel that sense of motivation for yourself,
实在是需要付出太多努力了。你基本上是在不断地推一堵砖墙。因此，这是一种将你困在自己良好意愿中的方式。这太不幸了，因为人们真的应该有机会吸收心理学、行为科学、神经科学的所有智慧，并为自己所用。如果我们只是对人们说，哦，我觉得你需要多一点动力，这就好比对人们说不要有防御心理。这会产生与你期望的行为完全相反的效果。因此，当你为自己感受到那种动力时，
because it's not, motivation is not bad. It's just not enough. What can you do with it? Instead of saying, okay, well, today, it's the 1st of January. I feel very motivated. I'm going to go out and run 15 miles and then I will eat a salad. And then I will get eight hours of very good quality sleep. A really good thing that you could do instead is I'm going to take that motivation and use
因为动力本身并不是坏事。它只是还不够。你能用它做什么？不要说，好吧，今天，1月1日。我感到非常有动力。我要出去跑15英里，然后吃一份沙拉。然后我要睡8个小时的高质量觉。相反，你能做的真正好的事情是，我将利用这份动力，并用它来
it to create a plan. I'm going to use it to find a buddy to support me in what I am doing. doing, I'm going to use that motivation to actually imagine what it's going to feel like in a week when I'm back at work and extremely busy and make a plan for that version of Julia rather than today's version of Julia. So can motivation be a fuel for people to change? Of course, yes. Does it last a very long time? No, it doesn't. And when it meets other obstacles, it is very often not enough in the face of those obstacles. And it is really, really unhelpful when we judge ourselves or judge other people for not having
它来制定一个计划。我将用它来找一个伙伴在我所做的事情中支持我。我将利用这种动力去想象，当我在一周后回到工作岗位且极其忙碌时，那种感觉会是什么样，并为那个版本的朱莉制定计划，而不是今天的版本的朱莉。那么，动力能成为人们改变的燃料吗？当然，可以。它能持续很长时间吗？不，它不能。当它遇到其他障碍时，面对这些障碍，它往往是不够的。当我们因为自己没有
enough motivation, not having enough willpower. It wasn't ever likely that they were going to be successful on motivation and willpower alone. I think about this all the time whenever, and this is a total like curveball to throw you, but we'll do the detour, come back. I think about this all the time when I see people, like, criticize people who are overweight on the internet, and they're like, just have some willpower, just have some discipline. And I'm like, that is honestly so ridiculous to think that that is enough and that that that was ever enough for you to change or ever enough for anybody.
足够的动力，没有足够的意志力而评判自己或评判别人时，这真的是非常、非常无益的。仅仅依靠动力和意志力，他们原本就不太可能成功。我一直在想这件事，每当——这是一个完全出乎意料的抛球，但我们会绕个弯再回来。每当我在网上看到人们批评那些超重的人时，我就会想到这一点，他们会说，只要有点意志力，只要有点纪律就行。而我想，老实说，认为这就足够了，认为这曾经对你或对任何人来说足够改变，是多么荒谬的想法。
Like the way that our environment, our childhood environments are set up, the way that our physical environments are set up, the way that modern society is set up means that it is more likely than not that you will not change your behaviour because of how exhausting it is to go against all your history, all like the stresses of modern life, all the coping skills that you have to change. So I love that you're saying, like, that's motivation and willpower, like, is not enough for anybody. And if for somebody to say that it was meant that there were probably other things going on, the tactile things, the relational things, the environmental things that are like also shifting at the same time. It's also such a good example. And if we can extend the detour,
就像我们的环境、我们的童年环境的建立方式，我们的物理环境的建立方式，现代社会的建立方式意味着，由于违背你所有的历史、现代生活的所有压力、你必须改变的所有应对技巧是多么令人筋疲力尽，你更有可能不会改变你的行为。所以我很高兴你在说，动力和意志力对任何人来说都是不够的。如果有人说足够了，那就意味着可能还发生了其他事情，那些触觉的事情、关系的事情、环境的事情，它们也在同时发生变化。这也是一个很好的例子。如果我们能把这个弯绕得
even a little further. What you ask about is such a good example of what we call in behavioral economics but also now in psychology the fundamental attribution error. And basically, I experience myself as a very complicated, unique, special, fully realized human being. I'm a complete person to myself. And even people that we know very well, very intimately, remain sort of strangers to us in all kinds of ways. We can not only never properly understand them, but they're never quite as complete as we are as a person. And so a consequence of that is we are extremely quick to both blame.
再远一点。你问的问题正是我们在行为经济学中、现在也在心理学中称之为“基本归因谬误”的一个很好的例子。基本上，我体验到的自己是一个非常复杂、独特、特别、完全实现的人。对我自己来说，我是一个完整的人。甚至那些我们非常了解、非常亲密的人，在各种方面对我们来说仍然某种程度上是陌生人。我们不仅永远无法真正理解他们，而且他们也永远不像我们作为一个人那样完整。因此，其结果就是我们极快地去责怪，
It was probably their fault and to judge. There is something wrong with them, other people in ways that we might not for ourselves. It's a really good example is if someone is late to a meeting or to an event, especially if we're inclined to judge them, we might say, oh, of course, they're very disorganized. This always happens. They're not respectful. And we've jumped really fast to, like, they're not a good person, they don't value our relationships.
这可能是他们的错，并以我们可能不会对待自己的方式去评判其他人。一个很好的例子是，如果有人开会或参加活动迟到了，尤其是如果我们倾向于评判他们，我们可能会说，哦，当然，他们非常没有条理。总是这样。他们不尊重人。我们非常迅速地跳到“他们不是一个好人，他们不珍视我们的关系”这样的结论。
Whereas, of course, in 100% of the situations where I have been late, there's obviously a very good explanation, usually outside of myself, the train was delayed, somewhere. what else really needed me, perhaps I was coming from a very important meeting. And so that fundamental attribution error, the tendency to externalize our own mistakes and to blame other people for their limitations is really dangerous because it not only prevents us taking a hard look at ourselves, but also prevents us being more forgiving, more welcoming, maybe even more helpful to that person. I do this all the time. I'm hearing you say that. I'm hearing you say that. I was like, oh, I did this this morning.
然而，当然，在我迟到的100%的情况中，显然都有一个非常好的解释，通常是我自身以外的原因，火车在某处延误了。还有什么更需要我的事情，也许我刚从一个非常重要的会议出来。因此，这种基本归因谬误——将我们自己的错误外归因并指责别人的局限性的倾向——是非常危险的，因为它不仅阻止我们严于律己，还阻止我们对那个人更加宽容、更加热情，甚至更加有帮助。我一直在这样做。我听到你这么说。我听到你这么说。我想，哦，我今天早上就这么做了。
There was like somebody walking in front of me. And I was like, that person is so rude. I was like, can't they see that this is a busy sidewalk? And then I literally did it like five minutes later. And I was like, well, that's different because, you know, and then I was like, no, it's not different. Like, I had to pause in the middle of the street to text someone. My thing was, I was lost. I was like, I don't know where I was going.
当时有一个人走在我前面。我想，这个人太粗鲁了。我想，难道他们看不到这是一条繁忙的人行道吗？然后我literally在五分钟后又做了同样的事，然后我想，嗯，这不一样，因为，你知道，接着我想，不，这没什么不同。比如，我不得不停在街道中间给某人发短信。我的情况是，我迷路了。我想，我不知道我要去哪儿。
I was like, well, this person probably didn't either. I know it's so interesting. Like, basically what we're just talking about is like empathy and like not judging other people's progress or. what they may or may not have, like, in their toolkit. I always think the first law of behavioral science is people are people, and so are you. And so you can be forgiving of other people while having very high expectations for yourself. And so indeed, people are people. And so are you.
我想，这个人可能也不知道。我知道这太有趣了。基本上，我们刚才谈论的就是同理心，以及不评判别人的进步或他们可能拥有或没有的工具箱。我一直认为行为科学的第一定律是：人就是人，你也是。因此，在对别人保持宽容的同时，你可以对自己的要求非常高。所以，确实，人就是人。你也是。
Yeah, I love that. Okay, let's talk about how we're going to change our behavior. You've been giving us so many little snippets, like little treats along the way. But I'm like, let's get a little bit of a guide down from an excellent. expert, what are, in your mind, some of the most scientifically successful ways to change behavior on an individual level, in a family level, in a relationship level, maybe even an organizational level? How do we make people, including ourselves, change? First, get specific, and second, get honest. So let's be really practical about it. And let's just talk about
是的，我喜欢这样。好吧，让我们谈谈我们将如何改变我们的行为。你一直在给我们提供那么多小片段，就像一路上的小点心。但我想，让我们从一个优秀的专家那里得到一点指导，在你看来，在个人层面、家庭层面、关系层面、甚至组织层面，有哪些科学上最成功的改变行为的方法？我们如何让包括我们自己在内的人做出改变？首先，要具体；其次，要诚实。所以让我们对此保持务实。让我们只谈谈
individuals for a second. Yeah. And then we can talk about much more enjoyable than trying to change yourself, trying to change other people. the best, let's say do that instead. But let's for the moment assume we have to make a sincere effort to change ourselves. Get specific. What is the behavior that you are trying to change? And so, for example, quit drinking is not a behavior. That's just a loose goal or it's a kind of category of activities that you don't want to be doing anymore.
个人一会儿。是的。然后我们可以谈谈——比试图改变自己愉快得多的是试图改变别人。最棒的是，比如说这样做。但目前我们假设我们必须真诚地努力改变自己。要具体。你试图改变的行为是什么？因此，例如，“戒酒”不是一种行为。那只是一个松散的目标，或者这是你不想再做的一类活动。
deciding not to have a second drink, for example, on any given night, we're starting to get specific on what you are seeking to do. It's very clearly measurable. So get specific. We've already talked a few times about the idea that writing a goal down, even if you never show it to people, is very helpful. It seems to trip some kind of cognitive switch for us. Asking people for help is another thing that you can do that is really powerful and useful. And so that might be, I have someone that I could text when I am thinking about, to extend this example, having a second drink that night. The other thing that you can do, and this works really well in organizations and teams as well, is like let's start to imagine what that future would be like if I make decide or I make this
例如，决定在任何给定的夜晚不喝第二杯酒，我们开始具体化你想要做的事情。这是非常清楚可衡量的。所以要具体。我们之前已经讨论过好几次这样一个观点：把目标写下来，即使你从来不给别人看，也是非常有帮助的。这似乎会为我们触发某种认知开关。向他人寻求帮助是你可以做的另一件真正强大和有用的事情。这可能是，当我考虑——为了延伸这个例子——那天晚上喝第二杯酒时，我可以发短信给某人。你可以做的另一件事，这在组织和团队中也运作得非常好，那就是让我们开始想象，如果我做出决定或做出这个
choice that I'm trying to move away from. If it has to have a lot of. If it has to be like, happens, if I want to have a second drink, if I think about calling that person who I actually have a pretty destructive relationship with, then what should I do? If I have this feeling, because feelings often precede our thoughts, then what am I likely to think? Like, I should call that person? And what should I do instead? Really important is that we have some kind of replacement for the behavior. So a good example in a pub would be, well, what would I order instead?
我试图摆脱的选择，未来会是什么样。如果它必须有很多“如果”。如果它必须像这样发生：如果我想喝第二杯酒，如果我想打电话给那个我实际上关系相当破坏性的人，那我该怎么办？如果我有这种感觉，因为感觉往往先于我们的想法，那我可能会怎么想？比如，我应该给那个人打电话？那我该怎么做？非常重要的是，我们要为这种行为找到某种替代方案。所以在酒吧里一个很好的例子就是，嗯，我该点什么来代替呢？
That might be a really good moment to know what my alternative order is. If you've never contemplated what you would order other than a second drink, it might be good to have a plan going in before you do so. And then the next thing to do is to say, well, once I've accomplished a really small version
这可能是一个很好的时刻，去明确我的替代点单是什么。如果你从来没有考虑过除了第二杯酒之外你还会点什么，那么在行动之前制定一个计划可能会很好。接下来要做的是，说，好吧，一旦我完成了一个非常小的版本
of that goal, we've talked about, it could be 24 hours of successfully. achieving the goal. It could be 36, it could be a month. Then what happens? What reward might I give myself? One of the funny things that happens is that the reward is often very motivating to us. We're like seduced by the idea of the reward. But once you get there, you find it wasn't that important to you. Like you didn't want or need the thing that you are going to reward yourself with because the goal itself has become and its own reward. So get specific upfront, get support, including from your own brain about what you're going to do instead, and then have your if-then escape plan.
实现了那个目标，我们讨论过，可以是24小时内成功达成目标。可以是36小时，可以是一个月。然后会发生什么？我可能会给自己什么奖励？一个有趣的事情是，奖励往往对我们很有吸引力。我们被奖励的想法所诱惑。但一旦你达到了目标，你就会发现它对你并没有那么重要。就像你并不想要或不需要那个用来奖励自己的东西一样，因为目标本身已经成为了它自己的奖励。因此，提前明确目标，获得支持——包括来自你自己的大脑的支持，关于你将做什么来替代它，然后制定你的“如果-那么”逃生计划。
Yeah, the if-then intentions are so good. I feel like very, who, I feel like James Clea wrote about them a lot in atomic, atomic habits. Atomic habits. And it sounds really basic, but one of the things that I love about it is it's not just, oh, there's a different plan, but that idea that we're kind of constantly on branching pathways and you say to yourself, oh, like, there are always a different set of choices. Like, there were always, this was always a choose-your-own adventure. I could always have made different choices. And this is just one of those moments where I can do that. I feel like this is what we keep coming back to is like you're in charge of your reality. Prove it to yourself that you can be in charge.
是的，“如果-那么”意图太棒了。我觉得詹姆斯·克利尔在《原子习惯》中对它们写了很多。原子习惯。这听起来很基础，但我喜欢它的一点是，它不仅仅是“哦，有一个不同的计划”，而是那种我们不断处于分支路径上的理念，你对自己说，哦，比如，总有一组不同的选择。就像，总有，这总是一场“选择你自己的冒险”。我总是可以做出不同的选择。而这只是我可以做到这一点的时刻之一。我觉得这就是我们不断回到的问题，就像你是自己现实的主人。向自己证明你可以掌控一切。
Exactly. And that no one cares more than you. No one will care more than you. But I hope the other really liberating thought, and sometimes this comes with time and sometimes you just have the opportunity to learn it is no one cares. And it's a really good version of that, which is you can do whatever you want because most people are just not paying that much attention. Oh, it's the best. Yeah. People are thinking an awful lot about themselves and how they're showing up in that situation and aren't finding whatever you are doing particularly memorable and in the best possible way, perhaps not even that interesting to them. I feel like that is a completely different conversation. But once you realize that, it's like, oh, wow, this whole, so much more about the world is possible to me when I don't have this entire part of my brain thinking about how somebody else is perceiving me when they're not, Like, it's a huge freedom, I think.
正是如此。没有人比你在乎更多。没有人会比你在乎更多。但我希望另一个真正解放思想的想法是——有时这需要时间，有时你只是有机会了解到这一点——根本没人会在乎。这是一个很好的版本，那就是你可以做任何你想做的事，因为大多数人根本没有那么关注你。哦，这太棒了。是的。人们花大量时间思考他们自己以及他们在那种情况下的表现，并不会觉得你正在做的任何事情特别值得纪念，而且以最好的方式来说，可能对他们来说甚至没那么有趣。我觉得这是一次完全不同的对话。但一旦你意识到这一点，就会觉得，哦，哇，当我不再让大脑的这一整部分去思考别人是如何看待我（而其实他们并没有）时，关于这个世界，我有更多可能性是可行的。我认为这是一种巨大的自由。
So Daniel Kahneman has said, like, nothing is important as you think it is while you are thinking about it. And I think the personal psychology version of that is, I'm just not as interesting as I think I am. Yeah. And that's a little confronting, but hopefully also wildly freeing for people, just not that interesting to other people. Yeah, you can put the spotlight on somebody else for a while. Following this vein of how to change behavior, the vein being the entire episode, But following this specific vein, what happens when you fail? You know, we've talked a lot about how you will try multiple times.
丹尼尔·卡尼曼曾说过，当你思考某件事时，没有什么事会像你想象的那样重要。我认为个人心理学版本的说法是，我其实并没有自己想象的那么有趣。是的，这有点令人面对现实，但希望对人们来说也是一种极大的解放，你在别人眼里其实没那么有趣。是的，你可以把聚光灯暂时投射到别人身上。顺着这个关于如何改变行为的主脉络，主脉络就是整集节目，但顺着这个特定的主脉络，当你失败时会发生什么？你知道，我们讨论了很多关于你会尝试多次的情况。
Likely, you likely will. I think I read the statistic that people try on average like 25, 30 times before a behavior sticks, if it ever does. What's the protocol then for when you've noticed that you've slipped, you've fallen, it hasn't gone the way that you wanted it to? Can I just say, I think that was the most important sentence in the whole episode. What happens when you fail? And so many people that I talk to, and I do a lot of work with CEOs or very senior executives,
很可能会这样。我想我读过一个统计数据，人们在行为真正固定下来之前平均会尝试25、30次，如果它真的能固定下来的话。那么，当你注意到自己滑倒了、跌倒了、事情没有按你希望的那样发展时，协议是什么？我能说吗，我认为那是整集中最重要的一句话。当你失败时会发生什么？我与之交谈的许多人，我与首席执行官或高级管理人员做了很多工作，
people much more established in their life and careers, refuse to use the phrase when we fail or when I fail. And we'll only talk about if we fail and are then very quick to say, but of course we won't. We will be in the minority who succeeds. But don't do enough to really push themselves, push the team to say, maybe it will be quite healthy to plan for failure. What happens when we fail? And assuming that we will both lets you in advance, say, well, I'm going to forgive myself first when that happens.
那些在生活和职业中更加稳定的人，拒绝使用“当我们失败时”或“当我失败时”这样的短语。而只会谈论“如果我们失败了”，然后很快说，但当然我们不会。我们将成为成功的少数派。但他们并没有做足够的事情来真正推动自己、推动团队去说，为失败做计划可能相当健康。当我们失败时会发生什么？假设我们会失败，这既能让你提前说，嗯，当那种情况发生时，我首先会原谅自己。
But then I'm going to do two things. The first is I'm going to declare a fresh start. And you might know the fresh start effect, which is that certain periods of time, your birthday, new year, a Monday can be very motivating for us in terms of declaring that now is the beginning of a new habit. We just seem to be a little bit more successful when we have had a fresh start. The thing that I love about this science and psychology is anything can be a fresh start tomorrow, the next hour, the next half hour, the more that you even say to yourself,
但接着我要做两件事。第一件事是，我将宣布一个新的开始。你可能知道“全新开始效应”，即某些时间段——你的生日、新年、一个星期一——在宣布现在是新习惯的开始方面，会对我们非常有动力。当我们有了一个新的开始时，我们似乎会取得更多一点的成功。我喜欢这门科学和心理学的地方在于，任何事情都可以是一个新的开始：明天、下一个小时、接下来的半小时，甚至当你对自己说得越多时，
I have the opportunity to begin again at any possible moment. And so if, for example, you have not started the day as healthily as you want and you're like, well, today is shot, I might as well eat a whole cake. You could also say 2pm is a fresh start. Nobody cares. There are no rules. Pick a time. Begin with a fresh start.
我都有机会在任何可能的时刻重新开始。因此，例如，如果你开始这一天时不像你希望的那样健康，而你想，“嗯，今天已经毁了，我不如吃掉整块蛋糕。”你也可以说下午2点是一个新的开始。没有人会在意。没有规则。选择一个时间。以一个新的开始开始。
The second is, instead of talking about what we have to. to do or what the rules or requirements are or what we think other people expect others, it could be really constructive to instead frame our goals in terms of expectations that we have of ourselves. What expectation do I have of myself? So I might have an expectation that I am a person who is able and excited to get up early and exercise. I might have an expectation that I am a person who gives help to other people when I can see that they need it, that I am kind or generous or a patient. And you see, all of that is part of saying, here's a set of qualities that I hope I have, that I would like to see more of in myself, and I'm going to look
第二点，与其谈论我们必须做的事情、规则或要求，或者我们认为别人对我们的期望，不如将我们的目标框定为我们对自己抱有的期望，这可能更具建设性。我对自己的期望是什么？所以我可能会有一种期望，即我是一个能够并且乐于早起锻炼的人。我可能会有一种期望，即我是一个当看到别人需要时能够伸出援手的人，我是一个善良、慷慨或有耐心的人。你看，所有这些都是在表达：这里有一套我希望自己具备的品质，我希望在自己身上看到更多这些品质，我将寻找机会去实践它们。我将寻找机会去证明这与我希望如何看待自己是一致的。因此，当我们失败时——我们所有人都一定会失败，宣布一个新的开始，然后提醒自己对自己的期望，会让我们下一次更有可能成功。我认为人们认为这是在给自己下咒或这是一种自我实现的预言，但这就好比，难道你不会宁愿要那个能够让你重回正轨的预言，而不是因为没有“如果-那么”计划而被彻底搞砸吗？是的，几乎可以说是拒绝去思考它本身就是一种自我实现的
for opportunities to practice them. I'm going to look for opportunities to demonstrate that that's consistent with how I would like to see myself. So when we fail, which all of us will, declaring a fresh start and then reminding ourselves what expectations we have of ourselves makes us much more likely to be successful the next time. And I think people think that it's jinxing it or it's a self-fulfilling prophecy, but it's like, well, wouldn't you rather the prophecy than actually was able to get back on track, like then it just be completely derailed by not having an if-then plan? Yeah, it's almost refusing to think about it is itself kind of a self-fulfill-
预言。我想说的是，你可以有一个预言，或者你可以有一个计划，但你不能两者兼得。我们确切知道的是，有计划的道路比只有预言的道路成功率要高得多。天哪，我喜欢这个。这是一句了不起的名言。太棒了。把它印在T恤上。我知道。我觉得，很多。你有帮助他人、带来真正改变的渴望吗？学院、城市，为您提供“依赖与心理健康”项目。掌握
prophecy. And I'd say exactly, you can have a prophecy or you can have a plan, but you can't have both of those. And what we know for sure is that the plan path succeeds much more often than the prophecy path. Oh my God, I love that. That's an amazing quote. That is so good. Put it on a t-shirt. I know. I'm like, much. You have the desire to help to make a real difference? The College, the City, you offer the program Dependance and Scenta Mental. Acquare the competences
陪伴和支持面临心理健康和依赖困难的人们所必需的技能。打造一份丰富多彩的职业生涯，
essential to accompany and support the people confronted to the difficulties of health mental and and dependance. Construise a career
为全国的法语社团服务。用法语从事健康工作，在
enriching to service of the community francophone of all the country. Don't know the health in French, it's possible
城市里是完全可能的。立即访问CollageLaC.com。这是加拿大卫生部资助的
with the city. Visit Collage LaC.com today. An initiative of the Consortium National
法国卫生培训全国联盟（Consortium National de Formation en Santes）的一项倡议。当时，感觉就像过了一个世纪。我以为我活不成了。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里空洞得没有任何东西。
of Formation in Santes Sautenue by Santee Canada. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes.
它们变得漆黑。这把我吓死了。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，长官。针对儿童的强奸和谋杀。再糟糕不过了。
They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape and murder for a child. She's as bad as it gets.
我想是这样的。人们，醒醒。我就是那个目睹克里瓦奇和德皮波行凶的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得无动于衷。我说我没有罪。我要把这带进棺材里。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《恶魔的采石场》。想要无广告收听《恶魔的采石场》并获取独家内容，请在苹果播客上订阅
I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder. placed by crevette and de pippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to
Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《与霍达·科特比一起探索快乐101》的主持人。在这里，我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话。比如当女演员奥利维娅·芒分享她是如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更加困难。有很多人理解产后抑郁症。我对外派焦虑毫无准备。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《与霍达·科特比一起探索快乐
Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
101》。每个人都感到非常兴奋，因为他们的新星是哈维尔·奇恰里托·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我当成一个足球运动员，但在成为任何东西之前，
podcasts. Everyone is a ton of exciting because their new star is Javier Tichorito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player but before anything else
我是个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存。自从我出生以来。我依然有这么多的疑问。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？
I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death?
你如何应对被取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？从日常的平凡到深邃的不凡。这不是一个普通的播客。
How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa? From every day an ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast.
这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深度交谈，脆弱感在这里流露。阴谋论被摆上台面，目标和人生经验得以分享。生命中的一切都有着完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等等，我将能够
Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life, has an order perfect and all is just. Wait, me, I'm going to be able to be
回来。我们来到这里是为了连接。小豌豆。我是哈维尔·埃尔·奇恰里托·埃尔南德斯，与iHeart Radio一起，我们要将平凡化为不凡。请持续关注。真是一个球星。在iHeart Radio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。主流媒体充满了对无家可归者的残酷描绘，这些故事羞辱、指责并将无家可归者描绘成一个铁板一块的整体。
come back. We are here to connect. The Chicharito. I'm Javier El Chicharito-Randes, and together with IHA Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It's a crack. Listen to learning to be human
《我们，无家可归者》是一档正在改变这一现状的播客。我是蒂奥·亨德森，创作者兼主持人，
or IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Mainstream media is full of cruel depictions of the unhoused, stories that shame and blame and paint the unhoused as a monolith. We The Enhouse is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson, creator and host,
多年来，我创造了一个空间，让无家可归者和他们的倡导者能够讲述他们自己的故事。仅在过去几个月中，我就采访了无家可归的父母、移民、互助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQIA+社群，以及制定影响无家可归者生存状况的法律的政策制定者。《我们，无家可归者》是一档获得两次韦比奖和西格尔奖的节目，未来还有许多令人兴奋的嘉宾。
and for years I've created a space where the unhouse and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed Unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. We'd be in-hous is a two-time webby and signal award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon.
本周请收听我对吉尔·威乔尔医生的采访。她是一位街头医生转型的网红，她对无家可归者社群的工作在网上和她的社区产生了巨大影响。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《我们，无家可归者》。在我们结束之前深入探讨一下，我们如何对待那些拒绝改变的人？我知道我们已经讨论了很多关于这种关系因素的内容。你知道，也许你的父母拒绝改变。你有一个拒绝改变的伴侣。
Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Jill Wichor. A street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge impact online and in her community. Listen to Wey and Howls on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Get into this before we end up wrapping up, how do we handle people who refuse to change? So I know we've spoken a lot about this relational factor. You know, maybe you have parents who refuse to change. You have a partner who refuses to change.
你有一些朋友在助长问题，就像你可能也在助长他们一样。我们该怎么办？我们是否该指出他们的行为？我们什么时候才决定也许我们不应该处于那种情况？这是一个微妙的平衡。对于处理这种情况的人，你有什么建议吗？花大量时间思考其他人需要如何改变是如此具有诱惑力。
You have friends who are enabling a problem. just as much as you are probably enabling them as well. What do we do? Do we call out their behavior? When do we just decide that maybe we need to just not be in that situation? It's a fine line. Do you have any advice for people who are dealing with that? It is so seductive to think a lot about how other people need to change.
相信我，我一生都在致力于改变。最好的一种情况是，你可以保持原封不动，而其他人必须改变。不幸的是，这种情况并不多见。因此，与其让我们的精神和情感精力占据在别人需要如何改变的方式上，不如做一个最安全的假设：你无法改变别人。并不是说别人不会改变。他们当然会。你能让别人改变吗？不。
Trust me, I spend my whole life working on change. And the best is the kind where you get to stay exactly the same and other people have to change. Unfortunately, there's not a whole lot of that out there. And so instead of really, I'm going to say occupying our mental and emotional headspace with the ways that other people need to change, the safest assumption is that you can't change other people. It's not that other people don't change. Of course they do. Can you make someone else change? No.
一般来说，你不能。所以你能做的、你永远能够掌控的是你对那个人的反应。理解为什么那个人会如此触发你的情绪是一个很好的步骤。因为你可以继续改变你们的关系，比如你花在他们身上的时间数量，你如何度过这些时间，你做什么，或者你如何对他们对你说的话做出反应，无论那是来自父母的建议。这并不意味着你有义务去做他们建议你做的事情，或者为什么别人对冲突的渴望在如果你选择抽身离开时，
Generally, you can't. And so what you can do, what you are always in. control of is your response to that person. And understanding why that person is so triggering for you is a really good step to take. Because you can continue to change your relationship, both like the quantity of time that you spend with them, for example, how you spend that time, what you do, or how you react to what they say to you, whether that is advice from a parent. That doesn't make it an obligation to do what they suggested that you do or why someone else's appetite for conflict doesn't have to turn into an argument if you choose to remove yourself
就不必演变成争吵。然而，有时我们会觉得自己已经告诉过某人去改变，建议过他们去改变，而他们仍然没有改变。很容易将这一点解读为那个人对你的不尊重。我认为在实践中，实际上有一个非常有用的策略来自家庭治疗，或者关于阐明你可能有的需求或你可能希望人们改变的愿望的夫妻治疗。基本上是这样的。这被称为“清晰且具体的请求”，因为这正是它的本质。通常情况下，有人会跟我谈论
from the situation. However, sometimes we feel like we've told someone to change, suggested that they change, and they still haven't changed. And it's really easy to interpret that as a statement of disrespect from that person's towards you. And I think there's actually a really useful tactic in practice that comes from family therapy, actually, or couples therapy around articulating a need that you might have or a desire that you might have for people to change. It's basically this. It's called a clear and specific request because that is exactly what it is. And so often someone will talk to me about
他们生活中的某个人。那可能是他们团队中的人。那可能是他们的老板。那可能是浪漫伴侣或朋友，他们会说，哦，这个人，这里有我认为他们不对的所有地方。我真的觉得他们应该彻底改变。我通常会说，你提出过清晰且具体的请求吗？当你在我们的晚餐迟到15分钟时，我将其解读为对我和我的时间的不尊重。你觉得以后提前五分钟做计划可能吗？清晰且具体的请求。这不是陷阱。
a person in their life. It could be a person on their team. It could be their boss. It could be a romantic partner or a friend and they'll say, oh, this person, here are like all the things that I think are wrong with them. And I just really think they should completely change. And I will usually say, have you made a clear and specific request? When you are 15 minutes late for our dinners, I interpret that as a sign of disrespect for me and for my time. Do you think it would be possible for you to plan to be five minutes early in the future. Clear and specific request. It's not a trap.
他们可以自由拒绝。他们可以自由地说这对我来说不切实际。这不是对你权力的滥用和对关系的滥用，但你提出了一个清晰且具体的请求。也许他们能对这个请求作出回应。也许他们不能。但你至少会知道你已经尽了你的责任。我确信在改变别人的行为方面毫无成效的做法是
They're free to refuse. They're free to say that isn't practical for me. It's not an abuse of your power and abuse of the relationship, but you've made a clear and specific request. And maybe they can respond to that request. Maybe they can't. But you at least will know that you have done your part. What I know for sure is not successful in changing anyone else's behavior
向第三者抱怨。这与成功的策略背道而驰。这很有趣。这在情感上非常令人满意。不幸的是，它起作用的概率为零。是的。这通常感觉像是情感处理，对吧？有时我认为我们认为我们对他们行为的反应是问题所在，
is complaining about it to a third person. That is the opposite of a successful strategy. It's enjoyable. It's very emotionally satisfying. It unfortunately works 0% of the time. Yeah. And it so often feels like emotional processing, right? Sometimes I think we think that our reaction to their behavior is the problem,
这可能确实是问题所在，我们需要克服它，但我们不是和他们一起克服它，而是试图在一个并非那个人的身上寻找清晰度。这非常像是通过拐弯抹角的方式，让另一个人成为你应该对那个人真正说的话的替身。我觉得所有人际交往关系、人际心理学中最有用的问题是：你试过跟他们谈过这个吗？我知道。
which it probably is, and we need to work through it, but we work through it not with them, and we're like trying to find clarity in somebody who isn't that person. it's very like a roundabout way of like the other person becomes a proxy for what you really should be saying to like the individual. I feel like the most useful question in all of the intergroup relations, interpersonal psychology is have you tried talking to them about it? I know.
这可能确实存在，我们需要去解决它，但我们解决它不是通过他们，我们试图在那个并不是那个人的身上寻找清晰感。这非常像一种拐弯抹角的方式，另一个人成了你真正应该对那个人说的话的代用品。我觉得所有群体间关系、人际心理学中最有用的问题是，你试过跟他们谈过这件事吗？我知道。
Like so often you don't even need the second question. I know. I know, but it's so difficult, isn't it? So often I will say to people, have you tried talking to them about it, especially in a professional setting. And often people will say, well, I was sort of hoping you would talk to them about it. That's why we're having this conversation. And I think you're so right to say, it can be very helpful for you to process to understand your reaction, to actually figure out, is it as a younger person in my life said to me recently, is it an issue or is it an ish them?
很多时候你甚至不需要第二个问题。我知道。我知道，但这太难了，不是吗？很多时候我会对人们说，你有没有尝试过去和他们谈谈，尤其是在专业场合。而人们经常会说，嗯，我其实是希望你能去和他们谈谈。这就是我们现在在对话的原因。我觉得你说的太对了，去梳理并理解你自己的反应，去真正弄清楚——正如我生活中一个较年轻的人最近对我说的那样——这究竟是一个问题（issue），还是他们的问题（ish-them）？
That's a more t-shirts are going to be printed. It's coming your way. Is it an issue? or is it it is them? And that conversation can be useful. It's just not going to change the other person's behavior. But if we also have pretty low expectations for other people and their ability to change their behavior, that can actually be pretty empowering for us because it's a reminder, oh, what I can change, what I can control is my own behavior. Yeah.
这个梗会有更多T恤被印出来。它马上就要来了。这究竟是一个问题，还是他们的问题？这种对话可能很有用。它只是不会改变另一个人的行为。但如果我们对其他人及其改变行为的能力抱有相当低的期望，这实际上会对我们很有赋能作用，因为这是一个提醒：哦，我能改变的、我能控制的，是我自己的行为。是的。
And often I think that actually is, again, another very, very freeing thing, you know, just being like, okay, cool. So this isn't, this situation isn't making me happy. It's not, you're not responsible for others' emotions and they're not responsible for mine. You know what I mean? I feel like that's a very empowering thing about behavioral change. It's just realizing like nobody's going to come and save me. Nobody's going to come and fix me.
而且我经常觉得，这实际上又是另一个非常非常让人解脱的事情，你知道的，就是觉得：好吧，酷。所以这不是，这个情况并没有让我快乐。这不是——你不对别人的情绪负责，他们也不对我的情绪负责。你知道我的意思吗？我觉得这是关于行为改变的一个非常赋能的点。它只是让你意识到，没有人会来拯救我。没有人会来修复我。
This is completely my obligation and that's terrifying and also incredibly freeing that I don't need to really answer to anybody if I'm like, well, I do, but as in like that I don't, like, I can just take control. Like it's up to me. I can make it the decision that I want to be different and just go and do it. One of the most useful things, maybe the only useful thing we can really do is be self-accountable. One of the most confronting chunks of psychology that I read about is basically the body of literature that says almost no matter how well we know a person or how long we have known a person, it is very difficult to accurately predict someone's feelings or thoughts in response to a situation. So every time you're telling yourself a story that you have to do something because of a,
这完全是我的责任，这既让人感到恐惧，又无比解脱——如果我觉得我不需要真正向任何人交代的话……嗯，我是需要，但我的意思是，我不需要向别人交代，我可以掌控一切。这全由我决定。我可以做出我想改变的决定，然后直接去付诸行动。最有用的事情之一，也许是我们真正能做的唯一有用的事情，就是对自己负责。我读到的最令人震撼的心理学片段之一，基本上是这样一批文献：几乎无论我们多么了解一个人，或者我们认识一个人多久了，面对某种情况时，要准确预测某人的感受或想法都是非常困难的。所以，每当你告诉自己这样一种说法：因为另一个人会很不高兴，或者因为他们期待你这样做，或者因为你做了或没做什么他们会看不起你，所以你必须做某事。
another person will be so upset or because they are expecting you to do that or because they will think badly of you if you do or don't do something. Actually, just reminding yourself that you might not be as good a reader of people. You might not be, in particular, a very good reader of this person can actually free you up to see a whole different set of choices. Oh, I'm literally I'm just thinking about myself there and being like, yeah, that's totally right. The amount of times I've been like, oh, my friend's totally going to react this way, or my partner is going to react this way. It's like that never, I don't really think I've ever been able to predict it. A fun thing that I really love about it is like there's some emerging research that says in
实际上，只要提醒自己：你可能并不那么擅长看透别人。你可能，尤其是并不擅长看透这个人，这实际上能解放你，让你看到一套完全不同的选择。哦，我字面意思——我刚才就在想自己，然后觉得：对，完全是这样。我有多少次觉得，“哦，我朋友绝对会这样反应”，或者“我伴侣会这样反应”。结果就是，从没有——我真的不觉得自己曾经预测准过。我非常喜欢的一个有趣事实是，有一些最新研究表明，在
certain situations, the better you know someone, the worse you are likely to be at predicting their thoughts or feelings in a specific situation, which could be really confronting the world. It suddenly feels very unstable. But I kind of love it as a way of saying that people can still surprise you, that all kinds of things could happen in a relationship that feels extremely stable or extremely concrete, that actually we could continue to have new things happen in this relationship. And that every time I encourage people to do this, go out and look for the unexpected reaction in your close friends, romantic partners, colleagues that you work with. I think it's actually a very fun thing when you say to yourself,
某些情况下，你越了解一个人，你在特定情况下预测其想法或感受的准确度可能就越差，这可能会让人感到非常震惊。世界突然感觉变得非常不稳定。但我有点喜欢这种观点，它意味着人们依然会给你带来惊喜，在一段感觉极其稳定或极其具体的感情中，各种事情都可能发生，实际上，我们可能会在这段关系中不断经历新鲜事。并且，每当我鼓励人们这样做时——去寻找你亲密朋友、浪漫伴侣、共事同事身上那些意料之外的反应——当你对自己说出这句话时，其实是一件非常有趣的事：
did not expect Gemma to say that. Yeah, there we go. Okay, let's talk about your book. Can we talk about it? I would be delighted. From my bookshelf over yonder. I was going to say, I was going to explain it, but that's not my book. So you have to explain it for me and tell us about it.
“真没想到杰玛会这么说。”好，就这样。好吧，我们来聊聊你的书。我们可以聊聊吗？我求之不得。从我那边的书架上拿下来。我本来想说，我来解释一下，但那不是我的书。所以你得帮我解释一下，给我们讲讲它。
Let me start by talking about why we wrote it, which was pretty much the same motivation for all of the work you do, which is a lot of our efforts to change in large organizations, even small teams or if you're a solo entrepreneur are not very successful. We're actually disappointing much more often than we succeed. But there is a science to success as well, which is what we put together in the book, that groups of people can do big things together really well. And from the world of airlines, fashion, food and beverages, from restaurant kitchens and factories, we tell all of these stories about people who have successfully.
让我从我们为什么要写这本书说起，这其实和你们所做的所有工作的动机差不多，那就是我们在大型组织、甚至小团队中做出的许多改变尝试，或者如果你是个体创业者，其实都不是那么成功。事实上，我们遭遇失望的频率远远高于成功的频率。但成功也是有科学方法的，这正是我们在书中整理的内容：一群人可以把大型活动一起做得非常好。从航空、时尚、餐饮、餐厅厨房到工厂的世界里，我们讲述了所有这些关于人们成功的故事：
experimented with the science of change and brought it into their own lives and into the work that they do. And what we're trying to do is create a bit of a challenge to our kind of very standard model in a lot of workplaces where a change is coming and we basically say to people, shut up and change. And instead, invite people to be part of the conditions where they can change successfully. And it's called How Change Really Works. If you were listening rather than watching. What is the, I don't want to say a fun fact? What is the most interesting thing in that book that you think is the most interesting?
他们试验了变革的科学，并将其带入自己的生活和工作中。而我们正试图做的是，对许多工作场所中非常标准的模式提出一点挑战：当变革来临时，我们基本上对人们说：“闭嘴，然后改变。”相反，我们邀请人们成为创造成功改变条件的一部分。这本书叫做《变革究竟是如何运作的》（How Change Really Works）。如果你是在听节目而不是看视频的话。有什么——我不想说“趣事”——你觉得这本书中最有趣的事情是什么？
Maybe it's a story, maybe it's a fact. I don't know. It's up to you in the book that people can look forward to more of. The original experiment behind this book was with 7,000 people around the world asking them about their feelings or reactions to change your work. We were trying to figure out the answer to the question, is it true that people just don't like to change? Are people allergic to change?
也许是一个故事，也许是一个事实。我不知道。由你决定，书中还有更多内容可供读者期待。这本书背后的最初实验对象是全球7,000人，我们询问了他们对工作中变革的感受或反应。我们试图找出这个问题的答案：人们真的只是不喜欢改变吗？人们对改变过敏吗？
And the answer is no. When we ask people, how do you feel about a change that is coming? About half the time, people feel quite positive about it. And when we ask them what feelings they have, they say I feel curious, but also anxious. And so we have an openness to change. And also a great deal of uncertainty about it. But I think as soon as you know that about yourself, about other people, you can start to say,
而答案是：不会。当我们问人们，你对即将到来的改变有什么感觉时？大约有一半的时间，人们对此感觉相当积极。当被问及他们有什么感受时，他们说我感到好奇，但也感到焦虑。因此，我们对变革抱有开放的态度。同时对它也存在很大的不确定性。但我觉得，一旦你对自己、对其他人有了这种了解，你就可以开始说：
how do I then shift the conversation really quickly from change as an obligation, something you have to do, to that invitation to be better. That is so cool. When is it available? Comes out May 19th, how change really works. There we go. We have one final question for you. We, me.
如何才能非常迅速地将对话从“变革是一种义务，是你不得不做的事”转变为“通往更好的邀请”？这太酷了。什么时候上市？5月19日发售，《变革究竟是如何运作的》。好啦。我们还有一个最后的问题要问你。我们，我。
I always do. Do you do that? When you're like, we, like, we ever, I think that's nice though, isn't it? I don't know. I just, I've been trying to stop doing that. That's my bad habit. Oh, who was, like, in your mind, who are the other, like, we's? Well, I think it's an Australian thing that I do where, I don't know if you're the same
我总是这样。你也会这样吗？当你像说“我们，我们总是……”时，不过我觉得这样挺好的，不是吗？我不知道。我只是，我一直在努力戒掉这个习惯。这是我的坏习惯。哦，在你的脑海里，还有谁是那种“我们”？嗯，我觉得这是一个我身上体现出来的澳大利亚特色，我不知道你是不是也一样：
where I think Australians are very much like, oh, you can't take credit for things. So you always say we. It's like, no, it's just I. Do you know what I mean? Like, I do. Yeah. It's true because I think in the United States would be, like, much more natural for something. Yeah.
我觉得澳大利亚人非常倾向于——哦，你不能把功劳全归于自己。所以你总是说“we（我们）”。就像是，不，其实应该说“I（我）”。你知道我的意思吗？就像，我确实会这样。是的。这是真的，因为我觉得在美国，这样说会自然得多。
I, like, have, like, this question. Like I have even, I think especially for Australians, it's if you, if someone has helped you. So for example, you're like, oh, I actually like didn't write the final version of this question. I can't say I have a question. Yeah. This is why I say to people, you need to have American friends. Like all of my like Australian British friends, I was like, we need to get you, everybody should be prescribed an American friend. Because they really, I think, I just have like an ability to really talk about themselves more accurately, even if it like might come off as arrogant, like more accurately than people who are humble.
我，就像，有，像这样一个问题。就像我甚至觉得，特别是对于澳大利亚人来说，如果是别人帮了你。例如，你会说：“哦，其实我并没有写完这个问题的最终版本。我不能说我有一个问题。”是的。这就是为什么我对人们说：你需要有美国朋友。就像我所有的澳大利亚和英国朋友一样，我当时说：“我们得让你去，每个人都应该标配一个美国朋友。”因为他们真的，我觉得，我就是有那种能够更准确地谈论自己的能力，即使这可能显得有点傲慢，但比那些假谦虚的人要准确得多。
the time. I think that sense of the personal narrative, manifest destiny, like, where I'm meant to be. But one of the things I really appreciate is the hype squad. I'm excited to cheer for other people as well. Yeah, I know. Tangents. I'm keeping that in. I love a chit-chat. I never get anything done because I'm always doing things like this and chat. I'm talking to people. Anyways, my final question, I want to know. What is one piece of advice that you have for people in their 20s that has nothing to do with what we talked about today. We are always in the middle of the story. No matter what has happened to you, you're at the first day of a job or the last day of the relationship or the really messy, annoying middle
很多时候。我觉得那种个人叙事感、天命论，就像——我注定要成为什么样的人。但我真正欣赏的事情之一是“欢呼小分队”（hype squad）。我也很高兴为其他人欢呼。是的，我知道。扯远了。我要保留这段。我很喜欢闲聊。我从来都干不成什么正事，因为我总是在做这种事、聊天。我在和别人说话。不管怎样，我的最后一个问题，我想知道：对于20多岁的人，你有什么建议是和我们今天聊的话题完全无关的？我们永远处于故事的中间。无论你身上发生了什么，你正处于工作的头一天、一段关系的最后一天，或者是在生活中努力建立一个新习惯时非常混乱、令人讨厌的中期阶段。
of trying to create a new habit in your life. We are always in the middle of the story. And if you can be curious about how the story unfolds, interested in your own life and the way in which you're a character in other people's life, I think that also frees you up to be the hero of that story and to remind yourself that anything is possible in the rest of the story, no matter what happened in the beginning. And what was the biggest lesson from your 20s? In any given situation, I think there are things to be afraid of and there are things to be curious or excited about. And that's a choice.
我们永远处于故事的中间。如果你能对故事将如何展开保持好奇，对你自己的生活以及你在别人生活中扮演角色的方式感到兴趣，我觉得这也同样能解放你，让你成为那个故事的英雄，并提醒自己：无论开头发生了什么，在故事的剩余部分里，一切皆有可能。你20多岁时最大的教训是什么？在任何给定的情况下，我认为都有让人害怕的事物，也有让人好奇或兴奋的事物。这是一个选择。
You can choose to be afraid. You can choose to be excited. And it feels easier to choose to be afraid. That feels natural, or instinctive, maybe. But choosing to be excited opens up an almost unlimited set of possibilities. Oh, I love that. That's actually such a beautiful way to finish the episode. Oh, perfect.
你可以选择害怕。你可以选择兴奋。选择害怕似乎更容易。这感觉很自然，或者说出于本能，也许吧。但选择兴奋则会开启几乎无限的可能性。哦，我太喜欢这个了。这真的是给这期节目画上句号的一种绝美方式。哦，太完美了。
It ties everything up in a nice, neat boat. Choose to be excited about your change. Choose to be excited about your 20s, about your life. I feel like that's a beautiful theme. Oh, thanks for saying that. Well, thank you so much for coming on the podcast. I'm going to leave a link in the description for your book, which will actually already be out when this episode goes live.
它把一切都整整齐齐地收尾了。选择对你的改变感到兴奋。选择对你的20多岁、对你的生活感到兴奋。我觉得这是一个美丽的主题。哦，谢谢你这么说。好吧，非常感谢你来到播客节目。我会在简介里留下你书的链接，当这期节目上线时，这本书其实已经出版了。
Are you doing a launch party? Are you doing anything fun? Oh, okay. What's the most fun thing that you've seen? someone do, what did you do? For when like a book comes out or something like that. Um, well, I'm a big celebrating person. Good. So like I'm always, if there's an excuse for to get people together, I will always do it. Um, my friends like hired a boat for their book coming out, which was really, really fun. It was actually just so, I think they just wanted to hire
你们要办发布会吗？你们会做一些有趣的事情吗？哦，好吧。你见过别人做过的最有趣的事是什么，或者你自己做了什么？当书出版或者类似的事情发生时。嗯，我是一个非常热衷于庆祝的人。很好。所以如果有什么借口能把大家聚在一起，我总是会去做。嗯，我的朋友们为他们的书出版租了一艘船，真的非常有意思。其实也就是，我觉得他们可能只是想租
a boat in general. There's a lot of commitment. Like, it's not like I will stop by your book party. It's like you're either here when the boat goes and you are here until the end. And also, like, I'm going to read the book aloud to you. I know they, it will. It's not. It's not. It's It was really like we're kind of in your hands. Yeah. We've got to just kind of do it. But I feel like when this is so random, but a bunch of my friends are now writing books and I always say to people, because not random, they're amazing people.
一艘船罢了。这需要很大的投入。不像那种“我顺路去一下你的书友会”。而是：要么当船开走时你在上面，要么你就在船上待到结束。而且，还要向你大声朗读这本书。我知道，他们，会的。不是的。不是的。这真的就像——我们有点落入他们的掌控之中了。是的。我们只能顺其自然。但我觉得——虽然这听起来很随机——我的一群朋友现在都在写书，我总是对大家说——因为这不是随机的，他们都是了不起的人——
But I always say like make sure that the day it comes out, you do something really special because it's like a really big moment, but then often it kind of feels kind of flat. So hopefully you've got something fun planned. Oh, I like that. That's it. Have a good mental snapshot moment. We have plenty of things to do. Like we have plenty of media things to do on the night.
但我总是说，一定要确保在书出版的那天，你做一些非常特别的事情，因为这是一个非常重大的时刻，但之后往往会觉得有点平淡。所以希望你们已经计划了一些有趣的事情。哦，我喜欢这样。就是这样。要有一个美好的精神快照时刻。我们有很多事情要做。比如我们在那天晚上有很多媒体活动要做。
19th of May. One thing we're going to do, which I'm excited for, is, have you spent time in New York? Yeah, love. So Barnes & Noble on Fifth Avenue, we are going to do the window display over the holidays, but we are going to go there that day and sign a bunch of copies, which I think is emotionally very meaningful for the authors. It's maybe less meaningful for everyone else, but I feel I'm excited for that. Okay, you've got it all sorted. I feel like, that's going to be a fun mental snapshot. Because when my book came out, I just kind of hung out by my son. No, I know. It's so bad.
5月19日。我们要做的其中一件事让我很兴奋，那就是——你去过纽约吗？去过，很喜欢。所以在第五大道的巴诺书店（Barnes & Noble），我们将在假期期间做橱窗展示，但我们会在那天去那里签一大批书，我觉得这从情感上对作者来说意义重大。对其他人来说可能没那么有意义，但我为之感到兴奋。好吧，你们都安排妥当了。我觉得，那将会是一个有趣的记忆快照。因为我的书出版时，我只是在我的儿子旁边闲逛。不，我知道。太糟糕了。
And I was like, this huge thing just happened for me. And I was like, so maybe I'll go to the grocery store or my dog. You'd been working on it for a long time as well. So I mean that feeling of like, well, like it's done. Like I'm over it. Yeah, it's like when you get a degree. It's like when you graduate. Like so many things have like the work, work, work, work.
当时我想：这对我的生活来说是一件大事。然后我想：也许我该去杂货店，或者陪陪我的狗。你也为它工作了很长时间。所以我的意思是那种感觉就像：嗯，它完成了。就像我已经翻篇了。是的，就像你拿到学位一样。就像你毕业一样。有那么多事情——工作、工作、工作、工作。
And it's like out. You've got the piece of paper. The books out in the world. Like this thing is the project submitted. Yes. Yeah, I agree with that. No, you have to celebrate it. Yeah, you definitely don't.
然后它出版了。你拿到了那张纸。书已经摆在世人了。就像这件事、这个项目已经提交了。是的。是的，我同意这一点。不，你必须庆祝它。是的，你绝对不能不庆祝。
One of my favorite chapters in the book is called ending change. Oh. Because we think a lot about the beginning and we never think about the end. Like, okay, this is done. Like, how do we end change really well? There we go. Yeah. Have a party.
书中我最喜欢的章节之一叫做“结束改变”。哦。因为我们花很多时间思考开始，却从不思考结束。比如，好吧，这完成了。我们要如何完美地结束改变？就这样。是的。开个派对。
Duh. On a boat. That's the answer. That's a solution. Yeah, you can take that chapter out. I just gave it away for free. Well, I will make sure that if you're listening, you know exactly what about Julia's book and
废话。在船上。这就是答案。这就是解决方案。是的，你可以把那一章拿去。我刚刚免费把它送出去了。好吧，我一定会确保如果你在收听，能确切地知道朱莉娅的书是关于什么的
where to see her TED talks and where to see what she is up to. Thank you if you have made it this far. If you are listening on Spotify, leave a comment down below. What is the behavior that you were trying to change? Whatever it is. We are going to be an open book of promises to each other and promises to ourselves. You can of course follow us on Instagram. You can watch episodes on Netflix. You can do all of those things. There are like a million links in the episode description at this stage. So go there, explore. We have a substack. There's lots to be done with the podcast if you want to go even further on this episode or all of our other episodes. But of course, as I say, as we wrap up every single topic, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will
以及在哪里可以看到她的TED演讲，去哪里了解她的最新动态。谢谢你能听到这里。如果你在Spotify上收听，请在下方留言：你正试图改变的行为是什么？无论是什么。我们将成为彼此的公开承诺之书，也是对我们自己的承诺之书。当然，你也可以在Instagram上关注我们。你可以在Netflix上观看节目。你可以做所有这些事情。在这个阶段，节目简介里大约有一百万个链接。所以去那里探索吧。我们有一个Substack。如果你想在这期节目或我们所有的其他节目中深入了解，播客还有很多内容可以做。但当然，正如我所说，在我们结束每一个话题时：保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。我们
talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevec and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the Iheart radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
很快就会再聊。那双眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。吓死我了。恶魔，醒醒。我是那个在克雷韦克和德皮波看到谋杀发生的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出悔意的迹象，被判处最高刑罚后显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我要把这带进棺材。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方，收听《博恩瓦利》的《魔鬼采石场》。
Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now there's a new and exciting. way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotbe. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app.
快乐至关重要，却又难以捉摸。但现在有一种全新且激动人心的方式来开启你迈向更快乐生活的旅程。“快乐101”（Joy 101）。这是一个由我——霍达·科特布（Hoda Kotb）主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋且感人的直播聊天。打开你的免费iHeart Radio应用程序，
Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to do that. to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine.
搜索“Joy 101”并立即收听。由CVS呈现的霍达·科特布主持的《快乐101》。每个人都视我为一个足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我都首先是一个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何做到这一点：自出生起，如何带着问题、错误、人际关系和情感生活下去。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的每一件事都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。
Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do.
只关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·托尔纳德斯（Javier Tornandez），请在iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习成为人类》（Learning to Be Human）。每个家庭都有自己的秘密。但当你发现你的父亲过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那可不是一个无辜之人的眼神。每个人都在对我的身份撒谎吗？我感到无比绝望。我觉得这是我不得不做的事。
Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. For years, the Un-House has been presented as a monolith in mainstream media. Wheatian House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created the show while it was unhoused on the streets of Los Angeles.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深度卧底：顾家男人》（Deep Cover the Family Man）。多年来，无家可归者在主流媒体中一直被呈现为铁板一块。“无家可归者的声音”（Wheatian House）是一个正在改变这种叙事的播客。我是西奥·亨德森（Theo Henderson），我在洛杉矶街头无家可归时创作了这个节目。
We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast, the only podcast that shares unhoused stories and news from the unhoused perspective. Listen to Wey and House on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们已经成长为一个两度获得威比奖的播客，也是唯一一个分享无家可归者故事和无家可归者视角新闻的播客。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“无家可归者的声音”。这是一个iHeart播客，由真人保证。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。